WELCOME TO OUR FIRST
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR HEARING ON
STATE ADMINISTRATION FOR THIS
BEAUTIFUL NEWYEAR TWENTY TWENTY
TWO OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE PLEASE COME TO ROOM
FOR FORTY FOUR WE WILL START AS
A SUBCOMMITTEE. FOR THE MOMENT
TODAY IN ROOM FOR FORTY FOR THE
PANELISTS ON THE AGENDA ARE
APPEARING APPEARING REMOTELY
USING ONLINE TECHNOLOGY. WE ARE
ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
END OF THIS HEARING BOTH IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND ON THE PHONE
THE PHONE NUMBER TO CONTACT TO
CONNECT IS ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND SHOULD ALSO BE ON
THE SCREEN IF YOU'RE WATCHING
THIS OVER THE INTERNET. THE
NUMBER IS. 877-692-8957 THE
PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR FOUR FOUR. IF YOU
ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE
CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT. 916-319-2099 AND
STAND A STAFF MEMBER WILL ASSIST
YOU WE ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO
PROVIDE WRITTEN TESTIMONY BEFORE
THE HEARING. PLEASE SEND YOUR
WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO BUDGETS OF
FOUR AD ASM DOT CA DODGY OVIH.
AND WE'RE NOT DOING ROLL CALL
SINCE WHERE WE'LL COME BACK TO
THAT. WE CAN GET STARTED MISTER
LUCKY GOOD TO SEE YOU THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE THE FIRST ISSUE
ON THE AGENDA FOR TODAY IS THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE SOME BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT WHICH
IS ON SMALL BUSINESS RELIEF
GRANTS AN UPDATE. IN OUR FIRST
ITEM WILL PROVIDE AN
INFORMATIONAL OVERVIEW OF THE
SMALL BUSINESS RELIEF GRANTS
FROM LAST YEAR- PANELISTS
INCLUDE TERREL LYNN GRAY THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
OFFICE OF SMALL BUSINESS
ADVOCATE. BRIAN WEATHERFORD
WITH- THE- AND THAT TOMORROW
JOHNSON WITH- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TIM WEBER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT AND THAT'S A GOOD
START. MS GRAY MAY BEGIN. MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYTHING'S WORKING.
GOOD AFTERNOON- CHAIR CAMILLE
AND- MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS CAROLYN CRAIG DIRECTOR
AT THE OFFICE OF THE SMALL
BUSINESS ADVOCATE AND DAD THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY TO
REPORT ON OUR SMALL BUSINESS
PROGRAMS I WILL BEGIN WITH THE
SMALL BUSINESS KOPET NINETEEN
RELIEF GRANTS. AND DID THIS
PROGRAM HAS RECEIVED TO ASK FOR
BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT FROM
THE STATE TWO POINT FIVE BILLION
GENERAL FUND PLUS ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION IN FEDERAL FUNDS TO
PROVIDE RELIEF TO SMALL
BUSINESSES- IN THE AMOUNTS- THAT
BETWEEN FIVE THOUSAND AND.
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS.
I'M VERY BEEN NINE RAM OF GRANT
WITH ROUNDS SPECIFICALLY
DEDICATED TO NONPROFIT CULTURAL
INSTITUTIONS. AS OF JANUARY
TWENTY EIGHTH THIS YEAR THERE
HAVE BEEN. THREE HUNDRED TWELVE
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY ONE
AWARDS. TOTALING THREE BILLION
FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY SEVEN
MILLION. 700-406-0008 HUNDRED
EIGHTY FOUR DOLLARS. THE
COMMITTEE HAS RECEIVED A
BREAKDOWN OF ALL THE AWARDS IN
EACH OF YOUR INDIVIDUAL
DISTRICTS AND- BOTH SUMMARIES
BACKGROUND AS A WELL HE'S EACH
INDIVIDUAL BUSINESS AWARDED.AND
I DO WANT TO NOTE THAT TO HAVE
ROUND NINE AWARDS ARE STILL
BEING MADE AND AWARD STATE EIGHT
IS COME STANDARD I'M ON OUR
WEBSITE. UNDER PUBLICATIONS. AND
I WILL CALL YOU GET TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS S. BUSINESS. AND
CRACKED PROGRAM. THANK YOU MISS
GRAY- MISTER LUCKY DO YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS AT THE MOMENT.
THANK YOU FOR THAT. I DO HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS MISS GRAY- WE
SENT OVER A FEW SLIDES BEFORE
THE HEARING AND WANTED TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE DATA
COLLECTED. IS IT MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE DID NOT
COLLECT INFORMATION ON THE
APPLICANT POOLS BUT ONLY ON THE
AWARD EASE AND IF SO WHAT WAS
THE REASONING BEHIND THAT. THAT
IS CORRECT. AND WE DO NOT
COLLECT AN APPLICANT DEMOGRAPHIC
DATA WE ONLY COLLECTED DATA ON A
WARRANTIES. AND THAT INFORMATION
IS PROVIDED VOLUNTARILY. AND IF
I CAN SPEAK FRANKLY. WE JUST
DON'T HAVE GOOD DATA ON SMALL
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA- THAT
SMALL BUSINESS. AND LICENSING
AND PERMITTING IT'S DONE AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. AND WE DON'T HAVE A
PROGRAM TO COLLECT DATA ON OUR
OWN. ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE
LIMITATIONS ON THE COLLECTION.
OF PERSONAL IDENTIFYING
INFORMATION. TO DO PROPOSITION
TWO ONE NINE. NO THANK YOU FOR
THAT I AND I'M JUST CRIOUS AS
TO IFI WERE TO ASK WHAT IS THE
PERCENTAGE OF WOMEN THAT
APPLIED. FOR THE GRANT VERSUS
THE PRCENTAGE OF WOMEN THAT
WERE AWARDED A SMALL BUSINESS
GRANT HOW WOULD YOU PROVIDE ME
WITH THAT INFORMATION. I WOULD
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE YOU WITH THE
INFORMATION- THE NUMBER OF WOMEN
OWNED BUSINESSES THAT HAVE BEEN
AWARDED WE ARE INDEED TRACKING
THAT DEMOGRAPHIC AND FIFTY THREE
PERCENT. OF THE GRANT AWARDS TO
DATE TO- HELP ON TO WOMEN OWNED
FIRMS. I BUT IT IN REGARDS TO
THE APPLICANT POOL ITSELF I
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THAT DATA. AND IS THAT A
DECISION THAT WAS LIKE HOW IS
CAN YOU. REPEAT EXPLAIN AS TO
HOW THAT DECISION WAS MADE OR
WHO MADE THAT DECISION BECAUSE
THAT TELLS ME THAT WE DON'T HAVE
FULL AND ACCURATE INFORMATION AS
TO HOW WE CAN HELP. UP WOMEN UP
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS ACTUALLY
APPLY IF WE DON'T KNOW HOW MANY
ACTUALLY DID APPLY. THAT'S AN
EXCELLENT POINT- AND
UNFORTUNATELY I'M LIMITED BY-
THAT THE LOSS OF THE LAMBS AND
PROP TWO OH NINE PREVENTS US
FROM DOING THAT. THANK YOU NO I
UNDERSTAND THE PROP TO A NINE IS
. CHALLENGING AND THAT IT'S YOU
KNOW IT IS A VOLUNTARY BASED
INFORMATION BUT- WHEN. WHEN
SOMEBODY WAS APPLYING WAS THERE
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO
DISCLOSE THAT INFORMATION OR WAS
THAT ONLY AFTER. ON A VOLUNTEER
BASIS. YES THE YOUNG FOR ME IS
THE INFORMATION ON THE IS
PROVIDED ON A VOLUNTEER BASIS
AND I'M GONNA CALL HIM A
COLLEAGUE FOR HISTORY AS IT WAS-
NOT IN THE SEAT AT THE TIME THAT
THE PROGRAM ORIGINALLY STARTED
SO I MIGHT AS- ALL TO HELP
PROVIDE SOME OF THE HISTORICAL-
DECISION MAKING ON THIS IF
THAT'S THE RIGHT. CHAIR MADAM
CHAIR SURE THAT'LL BE GREAT
THANK YOU. NO HI CHAIR CARILLO
GOOD GREAT TO SEE YOU AGAIN-
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
JUMP IN HERE SO WHEN YOU YES
THREE APPLICATION PROCESS SOME
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA IS COLLECTED
HOWEVER IT'S ALL DE AGGREGATED
IN THE DECISION MAKING PROCESS.
SO THIS WAS ALL MY INTENTION TO
ENSURE THAT OUR DECISION MAKING
IS AN ACE ON- INDIVIDUALIZED
INFORMATION- I'M NOT SURE IF WE
ARE ABLE TO THE AGGREGATE THAT
ONCE THE PROGRAM IS COMPLETED
AND- YOU KNOW BY COMPLETED I
MEAN. NO MORE FUNDING AND NO
MORE ADDITIONAL ROUNDS- THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT I'M SURE WE CAN
CIRCLE BACK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATOR ON TO SEE IF WE
CAN- IF THAT CAN BE QUITE BACK
TO EACH APPLICANT- HOWEVER
BECAUSE AGAIN IT'S TERRY SAID
JUST TO REINFORCE BECAUSE THE
LAW IS WHAT IT IS IN CALIFORNIA.
WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT NONE
OF OUR DECISIONS WERE BASED ON
ETHNICITY OR SEX OR THAT TYPE OF
THING I THINK YOU IDENTIFIES
UNDERSERVED BUSINESSES AND SO
THAT IS WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT IN
ADDITION TO THE OTHER CRITERIA
THAT THE ALGORITHM IS BASED ON
LIKE THE GROUP LIKE THE.
BLUEPRINT LIKE GEOGRAPHY AND SO
FORTH. THANK YOU MISTER HAD A-
YEAH JUST REAL CENTER TALKING
ABOUT THE LITTLE OF
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OUTCOMES-
WHAT. ONE OF THE BIG OVERALL
ARCHING QUESTIONS I HAVE IS
WHETHER OR NOT GO BUSINESS BEEN
ABLE TO IMPLEMENT THE- THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT
PROGRAMS. AFFECTED LEE AND-
BECAUSE WE'RE ASKING FOR MORE.
GOMEZ NOW IS ASKING AND- YOUR MY
QUESTION IS DO THEY HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO ADMINISTER NEWLY
PROPOSED EFFORTS WHEN WE'RE NOT
REALLY SURE THE ITEMS WE FUNDED
LAST YEAR BEEN ACCOMPLISHED. IS
THERE ANY KIND OF METRIC THAT WE
CAN LOOK AT THAT HELPS US
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT-
THEY'RE BEEN POSITIVE OUTCOMES
MEASURED. I'M ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HAPPY TO. ADDRESS THAT I JUST
WANT TO BE CLEAR- ARE YOU
SPEAKING OF ALL OF THE PROGRAMS
OR ARE YOU WANTING TO DIVE
DEEPER INTO THEIR SMALL BUSINESS
COVERT RELIEF GRANT PROGRAMS.
WELL IT'S KIND OF A- A GENERAL
QUESTION BUT IF YOU WANT TO GO
SPECIFIC I'LL BE HAPPY WITH THAT
TOO. OKAY SO- WHY DIDN'T GENERAL
ANSWER TO THE QUESTION OF WE
HAVE BEEN STANDING UP IN A VERY
METHODICAL MANNER EACH OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT WERE IN THE
PREVIOUS YEAR STATE BUDGET- THE
AND HAPPY TO DETAIL THE MICRO
BUSINESS KOBE RELIEF GRANT
PROGRAM. WHICH IS TO BE
ADMINISTERED THROUGH THE COUNTY
IS A ONE TIME FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR GRANT FUNDING FOR OUR
SMALLEST BUSINESSES AND IN THE
STATE LESS THAN FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN REVENUE AND TO LESS
THAN FIVE EMPLOYEES WELCOME ONE-
IS COMPLETE WITH TWENTY SIX
COUNTIES HAVING RECEIVED A
NOTICE OF INTENT TO AWARD
SIXTEEN OF THOSE COUNTIES HAVE
FULLY EXECUTED CONTRACTS AND
REQUISITIONS HAVE BEEN COMPLETED
SEVEN COUNTIES ARE GOING THROUGH
THEIR LOCAL APPROVAL PROCESS AND
THREE HAVE YET. TO COMPLETE
THEIR DOCUMENTATION. FOUND TO
FOR THIS PROGRAM- THE IS ON WAY
ON THE S. CHIEF- CAL. GOVERNMENT
AND CHRIS THAT NON. TO APPLY ITS
GRANT MAKING ENTITIES OPENED ON
JANUARY TWENTY SIX AND WILL
CLOSE ON MARCH TENTH AND WE
EXPECT THAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO
ISSUE THOSE CONTRACTS IN THE
SAME MANNER THAT HE HAS DONE THE
OTHERS. ARE REGARDING THE DREAM
FUNDS A ONE TIME THIRTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR GRANT PROGRAM
PROVIDING MICRO GRANTS UP TO TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS TWO SEED
ENTREPRENEURSHIP AND SMALL
BUSINESS CREATION IN CALIFORNIA
. YEAH ALSO UNDER OUR TECH
ASSISTANCE NETWORK IS DOING
OUTREACH TRAINING AND ONE ON
ONE. COUNSELLING OF FOR THIS
PROGRAM AND WE HAVE A THIRD
PARTY ADMINISTRATOR DOING THE
GRANT DISBURSEMENTS. I WE
RELEASED THE R. F. P. TO SELECT
THAT THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATOR
IN EARLY JANUARY AND- DOES
NOTICE OF INTENT TO AWARD HAS
BEEN RECEIVED CONTRACT SIGNED
OUR TAPE CENTERS HAVE ALL
RECEIVED- CONTRACTED TENDONS. I
HAVE TWO FOR THEIR AWARDS I'M
FOR THE RESPECTIVE SERVICES THAT
I MENTIONED EARLIER. AND IN V.
INCLUSIVITY INNOVATION HUBS
PROGRAM- WHICH WAS A TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT I
TO PROVIDE TEN GRANTS TO
INNOVATION HUBS. ACROSS THE
STATE IS ALSO UNDERWAY ON THAT
POOREST PIECE THAT MISSION. WAS
ELEVENTH- THROUGH DECEMBER
SIXTEENTH WE RECEIVED TWENTY TWO
APPLICATIONS FROM ACROSS THE
STATE AND WE ARE CURRENTLY GOING
THROUGH THE SELECTION PROCESS
AND ARE SCHEDULED TO
ANNOUNCEMENT DATE OF FOR THAT
PROGRAM IS THIS WEEK AND WE
EXPECT TO CONTINUE TO. BE ON
TARGET THERE. WE ALSO HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA VENUES GRANTS AS OF
TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT
APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THREE LIVE BEING USED
CENTERS WERE SELECTED TO GO
THROUGH THE VALIDATION AND
VERIFICATION PROCESS. WHICH
TAKES ABOUT FORTY FIVE DAYS AND
I'LL WE EXPECT TO RECIEVE R. O.
NOTICES. OF AWARD SHORTLY.
LASTLY WE HAVE THE NINE TH
PERFORMING ARTS. ONE TIME
MILLION DOLLAR GRANT THAT WILL
COME GRANTS UP TO SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO ELIGIBLE NON
PROFIT PERFORMING ARTS
ORGANIZATIONS TO ENCOURAGE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND THESE
GRANTS WILL BE AWARDED ON A
FIRST COME FIRST SERVE BASIS. IN
250-005-0000 AND SEVENTY
THOUSAND DOLLAR ANNOUNCE AND WE
HAVE RELEASED A REQUEST FOR
PROPOSAL- THAT FROM ELIGIBLE
MAKING ENTITIES ON JANUARY
TWENTY FIRST- IN THIS WAS TO
SOLICIT APPLICATIONS FROM
ELIGIBLE ORGANIZATIONS TO APPLY
TO ADMINISTER THE GRANT PROGRAM.
AND WE ARE ACCEPTING THOSE
APPLICATIONS THROUGH TUESDAY
FEBRUARY EIGHTH I SENT THOSE
ARE- GENERAL UPDATES- REGARDING
THE OTHER PROGRAMS THAT WERE IN
THEIR PREVIOUS BUDGET. THANK YOU
FOR THAT IT LOOKS SOUNDS LIKE WE
STILL HAVE OUR HANDS FULL TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUT- YEAH BLESSING
YOUR WAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MR LACKEY- MISS GREAT WE HAVE A
COUPLE OF FROM MEMBERS ARE VERY
INTEREST OBVIOUSLY IN SUPPORTING
THEIR SMALL AND THEIR OWN
COMMUNITIES WHICH IS WHY I'M
ASKING THE WHY HOW DO WE NEED TO
STE AT THE END OF THE DAY
GATHERED AT DATARAN IT'S NOT A I
BELIEVE A PARTISAN ISSUE WE ALL
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT ARE SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE SUCCESSFUL AND
THAT WE ARE OUT DOING THE
OUTREACH NECESSARY. SO FROM
OTHER MEMBERS IN THIS IS A DID
GO BIZ DESIGN OR APPROVE AN
OUTREACH STRATEGY FOR THE FOUR
BILLION GRANT PROGRAM CAN YOU
PLEASE DESCRIBE THE OUT RE
STRATEGY USED BY THE FISCAL
AGENT TO DEPLOY THESE FUNDS
INCLUDING FUNDING AMOUNTS AND
WHICH ORGANIZATIONS WERE
DESIGNATED TO FOCUS ON WHICH
GROUPS OF SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
AND IN WHICH AREAS I KNOW YOU'RE
NEW TO THE POSITION SO IT'S A
LOT TO TAKE ON AND I HOPE THAT
YOU CERTAINLY APPRECIATE WHERE
WE'RE COMING FROM IN TERMS OF
TRYING TO JUST ENSURE THAT. THIS
PROGRAM THAT THE OUTRAGE
NECESSARY AMID A PANDEMIC. YES
MADAM CHAIR. IN I CAN APPRECIATE
THE PROGRAM ACTUALLY FROM BOTH
SIDES AND BECAUSE WHEN THE
PROGRAM. LAUNCHED AND I WAS ONE
OF THOSE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROVIDERS. AND RECEIVED. THE
INVITATION TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
ALPS REACH NETWORK. I AM VERY
PROUD. OF THE WORK THAT OUR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE NETWORK HAS
DONE- ON THIS GRANT PROGRAM. WE
HAVE MORE THAN EIGHTY CENTERS
THAT HAVE PROVIDED TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND ONE ON ONE
SUPPORT. TO THE BUSINESSES
ACROSS THE STATE IN THIRTY
DIFFERENT LANGUAGES. AND THAT IS
NO SMALL FEAT- V. OUTREACH
MATERIALS WORK WORK NEEDED. ON
THE USING. OUR INTERMEDIARY ENDS
THE INFLECT. OF EVERY SINGLE ONE
OF THOSE CENTERS AND THESE ARE
BOTH FEDERALLY. FUNDED CENTERS
TO ENUNCIATE NONPROFIT- CENTERS
THAT HAVE PARTICIPATED IN THIS
AND FRANKLY I DON'T THINK THAT
THE PROGRAM WOULD HAVE
EXPERIENCED THAT LEVEL OF
SUCCESS THAT IT HAS. TO DATE.
WERE IT NOT FOR THE INPUT END IT
VERY VALUABLE EXPERTISE. THAT
OUR NETWORK OF TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE CENTERS AND PARTNERS. HAVE BROUGHT TV AFTER. AND
GIVEN GIVEN THE- NUMBER OF SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT HAVE BEEN
AWARDED WE NOW HAVE A DATABASE
OF A REALLY GREAT NETWORK OF
SMALL BUSINESSES THAT WE DID NOT
HAVE BEFORE WHAT ARE WE DOING
WITH THIS NETWORK AND HOW ARE WE
CONNECTING THEM TO ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES AND ARE THEY ALREADY
CONNECTED AND- ARE THERE ANY
BARRIERS TO ACCESS I KNOW IN THE
LAST HEARINGS THAT WE HAD.
LANGUAGE WAS A BARRIER TO ACCESS
TO- READILY AVAILABLE WIFI OR
EVEN UNDERSTANDING HOW THE
PROCESS WORKS AND HOW ARE WE
BUILDING ON THIS PROGRAM.
EXCELLENT QUESTION- THAT IS ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT MY TEAM IS
WORKING ON NOW ON THE IS
COLLECTING THAT DATA AND
UTILIZING THAT DATA MOVING
FORWARD I AGREE WITH YOU ONE
HUNDRED PERCENT- THERE IS A LOT
OF DATA AVAILABLE BUT WE DO WANT
TO UNDERSCORE THAT WE HAVE AGAIN
NOT COLLECTED BIG DATA. ON ALL
OF THE APPLICATIONS BUT WE DO
HAVE THE DATA ON ON HER TO
DISSIPATING BUSINESSES ARE PART
BUSINESSES THAT HAVE BEEN
AWARDED AND IT IT IT IT WOULD BE
MY DREAM TO BE ABLE TO LEVERAGE
THAT AND TO PROVIDE DEEPER AND
WIDER I SERVICES TO THE SMALL
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA. DO YOU
HAVE A DATE IN MIND IN WHICH
THAT THAT IT'S GOING TO BE
COLLECTED IN A REPORT OF SOME
KIND AND IF SO BY ONE. WE WILL
COMPILE A PORTION OF THAT IN OUR
ANNUAL REPORT WHICH WE SHOULD BE
PUBLISHING. THIS SPRING  WE
HAVE A DRAFT OF THAT REPORT
READY NOW- AND WE ARE GOING TO
THE PROCESS. OKAY THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL CALLS FOR A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS ADDITIONAL
TO CLOSE OUT THE EXISTING
APPLICATIONS FOR THE GRANT
PROGRAM. ONCE THAT'S COMPLETED.
DO CAN WE GET A COMMITMENT FROM
YOU TO DO THE AGGREGATED DATA IN
TERMS OF WHAT YOU ARE ABLE TO
OBTAIN FROM THE VOLUNTEERED.
INFORMATION THAT PROP TWO OH
NINE DOES NOT ALLOW US TO
EXPLICITLY ASK BUT HAS BEEN
VOLUNTEERED BY SOME SO THAT WE
GET A CLEARER PICTURE AS TO THE
DEMOGRAPHY OF THE OR THE
DEMOGRAPHICS I SHOULD SAY OF
THOSE THAT APPLIED INCOMPLETE.
AND- THE PROCESS OF- THOSE THAT
WERE AWARDED. JUST SO THAT I'M
CLEAR ON THE QUESTION I'M HERE
ASKING AND WHEN THE PROGRAM IS
COMPLETE WILL WE BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE DATA ON THE APPLICATIONS
AND BE AWARDED. OR ARE YOU JUST
SAYING A FULL DEMOGRAPHIC
PROFILE OF THOSE ABOARD IT. I A
FULL DEMOGRAPHIC PROFILE OF
EVERYONE THAT APPLIED. AND
ULTIMATELY WILL BE AWARDED ONCE
THE ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION IF WE GET TO THAT IS
COMPLETED. MEANING THE FINAL
REPORT RIGHT NOW THE REPORT THAT
WE HAVE BASED ON THE GRANTEES
THAT WERE PROVIDED GIVE US A
SMALL GLIMPSE RIGHT OF
PERCENTAGES OF. WOMEN OWNED
BLACK OWNED MINORITY OWNED
LATINO OWNED AT CETERA. BUT IT'S
NOT A FULL PICTURE RIGHT BECAUSE
THERE ARE STILL APPLICATIONS
THAT ARE PENDING AND THE
ADDITIONAL HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
. THE QUESTIONS THAT HAVE ARISEN
FROM MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE
IS WE WANT TO KNOW. WHAT ARE THE
WHAT ARE THE RESOURCES THAT WENT
OUT LIKE WHAT IS THAT PROFILE
LOOK LIKE AND HOW CAN WE EXPAND
ACCESS AND RESOURCES SO THAT'S
WHAT I'M ASKING YOU ONCE WE GET
THROUGH THE ENTIRE PROCESS. WILL
YOU BE ABLE TO PROVIDE BASED ON
THE DATA THAT YOU HAVE A MORE
COMPLETE PROFILE OF EVERYONE
THAT APPLIED. YES MA'AM I'M SURE
WE WILL- CERTAINLY ASKING AND
HOW THAT CAN BE DONE. AND WE
WILL SHARE EVERY BIT OF THE
INFORMATION THAT THAT WE HAVE. I
AND I DON'T KNOW WHETHER OR NOT
MORE ALL YOU WANT TO JUMP IN
HERE IS THERE IF THERE'S
SOMETHING THAT YOU FEEL I'M I AM
I MISSING ON THIS ANSWER. YEAH
OF COURSE OF COURSE BOTTOM SHARE
WE WILL ABSOLUTELY PROVIDE THE
DATA WHICH WE CAN- THAT WHICH
YOU KNOW HOW HOWEVER UNLESS YOU
CAN PROVIDE IT TO US- THAT'S NOT
AN ISSUE I MEAN FOR THE PURPOSES
OF THE GRANT ADMINISTRATION WE
REALLY NEED TO THE SEPARATED IN
THE AGGREGATE WHICH I KNOW I
KNOW YOU. I KNOW YOU GET THAT WE
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT CANNOT
BE PATCHED BACK TOGETHER.
ADDITIONALLY ON THE OUTREACH
PIECE OF IT I DON'T CARE SAID
THAT- WE ESTABLISHED. A SLEW OF
NEW RELATIONSHIPS THROUGH OUR
NETWORK OF NOT JUST THE EIGHTY
ART. EIGHTY IN THE TAKE NETWORK
BUT ALL THE ANCILLARY PARTNERS
THAT CAME OUT OF THAT HOLE THE
CDFI IS A LOCAL- ORGANIZATIONS
AND SO THOSE ARE TOUCH POINTS
THAT THE CONTINUE TO HAPPEN
BETWEEN THOSE CENTERS AND THOSE
SMALL BUSINESSES. OUT LETTING
THEM KNOW WHAT RESOURCES ARE
AVAILABLE PROVIDING THE NEW
INFORMATION ABOUT NEW GRANT
PROGRAMS THEY MAY BE ELIGIBLE
FOR. AND KEEPING THEM APPRISED
OF ANYTHING THAT'S HAPPENING AT
THE FEDERAL OR LOCAL LEVEL
SHOULD THEY. BE A LOCAL
ORGANIZATION. THAT'S WONDERFUL
TO HEAR I KNOW THAT I'M NOT
ALONE WITH THEM. ENQUIRING ABOUT
HOW DO WE SUPPORT OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES AND HOW DO WE MAKE
SURE THAT THEY HAVE RESOURCES
AND OUR SUCCESSFUL. AT ONE FINAL
QUESTION BEFORE WE MOVE ON- CAN
ALWAYS BE PLEASE PROVIDE A
DEMOGRAPHIC BREAKDOWN OF THE
INELIGIBLE DUE TO DELINQUENT SOS
FILING THURS APPROXIMATELY
EIGHTY FIVE HUNDRED
APPLICATIONS. AND THE DIDN'T
MEET THE VERIFICATION AND
VALIDATION REQUIREMENTS- WHICH
IS ABOUT FORTY SIX THOUSAND
APPLICATIONS. ESL SPEAKING. LIKE
TO THE SOS FILINGS WE HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER I'M AS SHE
POINTED OUT A LITTLE OVER EIGHTY
FIVE HUNDRED THAT DEMOGRAPHIC.
BREAKS DOWN ON THAT IS
SIGNIFICANT AND TELLING THE AN
OVERWHELMING NUMBER OF THOSE
SMALL BUSINESSES ARE AND OWNED
BY A- FOLKS IN OUR
DISADVANTAGED- UNITIES AND
OVERWHELMING. NUMBER OF STAND
ARE. ALL I SAID HAS- 96% AND 67%
RESPECTIVELY. THANK YOU FOR THAT
MS GRAY AND BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO
WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS FROM. THE OHIO. WE
HAD NO- ADDITIONAL COMMENTS ON
THIS PROPOSA HIM AND THAT IT'S
ON UNDER CONSIDERATION FOR EARLY
ACTION- BUT IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR US AND WE'RE HAPPY
TO ON. THANK YOU KNOW ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS. NOTHING TO ADD AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU. OKAY. THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE CAN MOVE ON FROM THIS
PARTICULAR PANEL I JUST WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE WHO PARTICIPATED
AND LOOK FORWARD TO RECEIVING
SOME OF THOSE SOME OF THE
ADDITIONAL DATA SO THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS A MORE NFORMED
AS TO HOW THE FUNDING WAS
ALLOCATED IN WHICH SMALL
BUSINESSES- WERE FUNDED IN
ANYTHING MORE THAN WE CAN DO TO
SUPPORT A ROBUST ECONOMIC- I
REQUEST THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY
AS- WE MOVE FRWARD- WITH THEM.
PANDEMIC RECOVERY EFFORTS THANK
YOU SO MUCH. WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO. TOURISM
RECOVERY IS MISS OUT OF PHILLY
COMEBACK FROM METIS ON READY TO
GO. I'M HERE MADAM CHAIR LEADER
I'M COMING THROUGH OKAY YES
PLEASE. PLEASE BEGIN PERFECT
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
TODAY ON ISSUE TWO OF THE AGENDA
REGARDING TOURISM RECOVERY
EFFORT MY NAME IS OUT OF ANY
COMBAT I NEEDED SENIOR DEPUTY
DIRECTOR AT KOBE IS-
CALIFORNIANS. DISPROPORTIONAL
AFFECTED TRAVEL TOURISM MORE
THAN ANY OTHER INDUSTRY AS A
RESULT ALMOST HALF OF ALL
LEISURE AND HOSPITALITY WORKERS
HAVE LOST THEIR JOBS DURING THE
HEAD OF THE PANDEMIC AND LEISURE
AND HOSPITALITY REMAINS BY FAR
THE HARDEST HIT EMPLOYMENT
SECTOR IN CALIFORNIA THE
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF TOURISM
WITHIN GOBIZ WORKED IN CLOSE
COORDINATION WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TO PROMOTE THE STATE AS A
PREMIER TRAVEL DESTINATION. THE
CALIFORNIA ITS MARKETING DOLLARS
TO BENEFIT TWELVE TOURISM
REGIONS LOOK THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND KEY THANK HAVE BEEN
LEFT BENEFIT FROM TOWARDS
INCLUDE ACCOMMODATION RENTAL
CARS ATTRACTIONS RESTAURANTS
RETAIL AND TRANSPORTATION
SERVICES WE ARE REQUESTING A
FORTY FIVE MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND ALLOCATION TO
IMPLEMENT. STRATEGIC MEDIA
RECOVERY K. TO HELP TO THEIR
WORK OF THE TRIAL AND IN. AT THE
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF TOURISM
RECORD WITH THE K. TO IMPLEMENT
AND THEY SHOULD AFTER POINT BILL
- ADDITIONAL REVENUE IS EXPECT
FOR K. BUSINESSES ADDRESS OF THE
FORTY FIVE NOW AND RENT
APPEALING ONE POINT BILL IN
ADDITIONAL AND TAX REVENUE. AND
WE A PRE THE ART OF THAT OUT
THROUGH THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO BUDGET LAW YEAR AND A HALF
PLAN THOSE WILL DEPLOYED. I
SINCE THE SPRING CAN IN JUNE.
AND THE PANDEMIC VERY OF COULD
TO IN. OUR TRAVEL TOURISM. THIS
REQUEST WILL US TO CURRENT MARK
CAMP. ON ATTITUDE OF TWO TWENTY.
AND ALLOW ALSO US ADD DATA CAN
LED SPOKE ON FAMILY URBAN CORE
AND CULINARY TRAVEL AS NOTED THE
COMMITTEE'S AGENDA. ALSO THOSE
NEW CAMPAIGNS WILL BE ACTIVE.
WHICH IS PROMOTING CALIFORNIA
THE FAMILY FUN OPTION FOR THOSE
LOOKING TO REUNITE RECONNECT AND
LEARN HOW TO THE CATION AGAIN.
WE'RE LOOKING AT URBAN CORE
WHICH IS PROMOTING GATEWAY
CITIES THAT OFFER A BLEND OF
OUTDOOR SETTING AND CULTURAL
EXPERIENCES FOR TRAVELERS AND
THEN WE HAVE A CULINARY FOCUS
WHICH IS ENCOURAGING OF COURSE
THE FOLKS TO DINE OUT. AND HELP
OUR RESTAURANTS AND EMPLOYEES. I
A LOOK SPENDING PLAN HAS BEEN
AND IF I PAGE OF THE A- AND I'M
JOINED TODAY BY A- BACK. ARE
PRICED OF CAN. OUT HIS ACCOUNT.
AND OF COURSE MY COLLEAGUES FROM
FINANCE- HER HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM AS THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR THAT
MISS COMBERMERE IS BEFORE WE GO
TO THE DIETS FOR ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS. LET'S HEAR FROM MR
WHETHER FORD WITH THE L. L. ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. YES THIS
IS BRIAN WITH AFFORDABLE
LEGISLATURE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND- WE ARE ON. WE RECOMMENDED
REJECTING ADDITIONAL STATE
FUNDING FOR THE CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE IT APPEARS TO BE
UNNECESSARY- SO FIRST WE WOULD
KNOW WE WOULD WANT TO DIMINISH
THE IMPORTANCE OF TOURISM TO THE
STATE'S ECONOMY AND THE PANDEMIC
HAS HAD A TERRIBLE IMPACT ON
TOURISM BUSINESSES EVEN RELATIVE
TO MOST OTHER SECTORS OF THE
STATE'S ECONOMY DURING THE
PANDEMIC SO I REJECT- OUR
RECOMMENDATION IS BASED ON OUR
ANALYSIS OF IS THAT CALIFORNIA'S
REVENUES AND EXPENDITURES FOR
THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS- AND IT
ACCOUNTS FOR THE NINETY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDS THAT ME
ON. PROVIDED A BUSY CAL LOS YEAR
WELL VISIT CALIFORNIA'S REVENUES
DECLINE FROM A HUNDRED TWENTY
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR IN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN TO SEVENTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE HE
ORGANIZATION SHARPLY REDUCE ITS
EXPENDITURES AT THE OUTSET OF
THE PANDEMIC AND IT PRUDENTLY
BUILT ITS FINANCIAL. RESERVES SO
. HAS BEGUN RECOVER BUT LIKE
WILL DEPRESSED. FOR SOMETIME
BECAUSE OF THE PUBLIC CONCERNS.
AND WHILE THE BIG. ASSESSMENT OF
THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS LIKE WILK
. TO BE DEPRESSED. REVENUES
LIKELY TO DECLINE MUCH. OR
PERHAPS ANY FURTHER AND SO WE
FIND THAT THE NINETY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS THAT IS A
CALIFORNIA RECEIVED LAST YEAR.
REALLY SHOULD BE SUFFICIENT TO
ALLOW THE ORGANIZATION TO BE
ABLE TO SPEND SOMEONE ABOUT THE
PRE PANDEMIC LEVELS. WITHOUT
ADDITIONAL STATE FUNDS. THANK
YOU FOR THAT MISTER WHETHER FORD
ISER SOMEBODY FROM. THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE BUT MANY COME
OR QUESTIONS THEM. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR TAMARA JOHNSON
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAS
ASSEMBLY HAD MENTIONED TOURISM
WAS ONE OF THE HARDEST HIT
SECTORS- DURING THE PANDEMIC.
AND WE CONTINUE TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL WE THINK THAT THE FORTY
FIVE MILLION IS A REASONABLE
INVESTMENT- TO IMPROVE ON IT TO
SPUR TOURISM HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU. GREAT THANK YOU FOR
THAT- NOW WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
THE DENTIST FOR QUESTIONS MISTER
LUCKY. YEAH JUST REAL QUICKLY- I
JUST WONDERED ARE THERE ANY
METRICS. THE VISIT CALIFORNIA
IMPLEMENTED TO DETERMINE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE NINETY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS. FOR THE
MARKETING CAMPAIGN. AND IF NOT I
MEAN. IT'S PUTS INTO QUESTION
WHY WE'RE ADDING FORTY FIVE
MILLION MORE. ARE THERE ANY ARE
THERE ANY METRICS AND ALL THE
WITH YEAH I'M IN NIGER THE
SUCCESS OR LACK THEREOF. I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE THAT QUESTION
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LACKEY- WE DO USE BEST IN CLASS
AN INDUSTRY STANDARD METHODOLOGY
FOR EVALUATING THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF OUR TRAVEL MARKETING
CAMPAIGNS. IT'S BEEN A STANDARD
IN EXISTENCE WITHIN THE INDUSTRY
FOR THE BETTER PART OF TWO
DECADES- IT'S EARLY DAYS THE
BUDGET LANGUAGE- THAT WAS PASSED
LAST YEAR- MANDATE TO. AN
EXPENSE REPORT AND A AND
EFFECTIVENESS REPORTS- BUT I CAN
TELL YOU THAT IN THE FIRST SIX
MONTHS OF THAT NINETY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR CAMPAIGN TWELVE
POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS OF
INCREMENTAL REVENUE WAS
GENERATED FROM THE STATE'S TRIP
TO RISEN BUSINESSES- THAT IS-
AGAIN EARLY DAYS SO I'D- I'D SAY
PRELIMINARY BECAUSE IT'S FAR
FROM COMPLETE. THAT NINETY FIVE
MILLION WILL CONTINUE TO
GENERATE TRAVEL FOR THE NEXT SIX
TO TWELVE MONTHS WILL BE-
CAPTURING THAT AN ARTICLE
REPORTS OF THE LEGISLATURE.
THANK YOU. WHEN THAT FORMER TO
THE- BE COMPLETED. THE FIRST
PRELIMINARY REPORT THE BUDGET
LANGUAGE FROM LAST YEAR- IS DUE
BY JULY FIRST AND THEN A BISHOP
OF THIS CALENDAR YEAR AND THEN A
FULL FINANCIAL IMPACT REPORT IS
DUE JULY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. GREAT THANK YOU. AT THE
L. A- COMMENTS THE VISIT
CALIFORNIA REDUCE ITS
EXPENDITURES ADDS REVENUE
COLLECTIONS BLANK BEGAN TO
DECLINE IN TWENTY TWENTY. THIS
CALIFORNIA HAS INCREASED ITS NET
ASSETS FROM TWENTY MILLION FROM
THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
TWENTY YEAR TO FIFTY EIGHT
MILLION. BY THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO WITH THIS INCREASE IN
NET ASSETS HOW DID WAS A
CALIFORNIA DETERMINED. THAT
FORTY FIVE MILLION WAS NEEDED
FOR MEDIA THIS IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET. THE- THE L. A. ANALYSIS
- IS ACCURATE AND IT'S A
REFLECTION OF OUR NET ASSETS AT
THE END OF OUR FISCAL YEAR LAST
YEAR. I'D LIKE TO REMIND THE
COMMITTEE THAT THAT FISCAL YEAR
THERE WERE ONLY TWO WEEKS- OF
TIME IN THAT ENTIRE FISCAL YEAR
WHEN TRAVEL WAS ALLOWED IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE STATE
WAS NOT RE OPEN TO TRAVEL UNTIL
JUNE FIFTEENTH OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. SO IT'S REALLY- I THINK
THAT NASA NET ASSETS THEY ARE
REFLECTED ON THOSE FINANCIAL
STATEMENTS ARE A REFLECTION OF-
US SLOWING DOWN OUR MARKETING
WILL TRAVEL WAS NOT IMPACTED. I
CAN TELL YOU THAT WE ARE- IN
ADDITION TO SPENDING THE FUNDS
THAT WERE GRANTED IN THE BURKE
BUDGET PROCESS LAST YEAR WE ARE
ACTIVELY SPENDING DOWN THOSE
THOSE- INDUSTRY GENERATED FUNDS
NOW. OVERALL OUR INDUSTRY
COLLECTIONS REMAIN DOWN ABOUT
3235% BUT AND THIS SCHOOL YEAR-
AND WE DO CONTINUE TO SEE THAT-
IT IS FOR THE FORESEEABLE FUTURE
WHILE THE TRAVEL INDUSTRY IS
RECOVERING. OUR INDUSTRY-
GENERATED FUNDING WILL BE DOWN
TO- FOR PROBABLY THE BETTER PART
OF TWO TO THREE YEARS. I THANK
YOU FOR THAT BUT A SPECIFICALLY. WORDED THE FORTY FIVE MILLION
NUMBER COME FROM. FORTY FIVE. IS
A- WHAT IS IN KEEP FLAT WITH
WHAT ARE. X. ARE YEAR. BASED ON
THE NINETY MILLION LAST. OUR
INDUSTRY REVENUES HAVE RECOVERED
SOMEWHAT FROM THAT LAST YEAR
THOSE THOSE DARK EARLY DAYS THE
PANDEMIC OF COURSE- SO. FIVE
MILLION TO SIMPLY KEEP. WITH ME
WE ARE THIS YEAR AND THIS YEAR
GARCIA BACK HOME. OF STATE
FUNDING THAT THAT NINETY FIVE
MILLION PLUS THE INDUSTRY
GENERATED FUNDS- WITHOUT AN
ADDITIONAL. LEVEL OF FUNDING
FROM THE STATE WE WILL HAVE A
DROP OFF AND WHAT IS THE
CALIFORNIA IS ABLE TO DO. MIGHT
ALSO LIKE TO NOTE THAT A 100% OF
THESE FUNDS GO DIRECTLY TO THE
PAID MEDIA BY. NONE OF THEM GO
TO OVERHEAD OF ANY KIND STAFF.
SALARIES OR ANYTHING ELSE THAT
WOULD- WOULD TAKE AWAY FROM THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THAT- PAID
CAMPAIGN. I'M SO GLAD THAT YOU
BROUGHT UP THE PAID MEDIA BY.
FROM THE MEDIA COMPANIES THAT
YOU USE TO DETERMINE THE- WHERE
THE YOU KNOW THE DIFFERENT
CAMPAIGNS WHAT WENT TO. CAN
SOMEONE SHARE HOW MANY OF THOSE-
POTENTIAL MARKETING FIRMS ARE PR
FIRMS. FOR CALIFORNIA COMPANIES
. THIS THAT'S THE NEXT QUESTION
I- OR OR AGENCY OF RECORD ARE
ARE MARK FIRM BASED HERE IN
SACRAMENTO OF ALL- IN SAN DIEGO
AS WELL- THE MEDIA COMPANY THAT
THAT- THE- PURCHASES ARE MEDIA
AT SCALE FOR THE BOOK. BEST
EFFICIENCY ON THESE DOLLARS- IS
A GLOBAL COMPANY CALLED ABBAS
MEDIA. NOMINATORS CONTRACTOR TO
OUR AGENCY OF RECORD THE
SHIPYARD AGAIN BASED HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. I DON'T HAVE MY
FINGERTIPS AN EXACT ACCOUNTING
OF. WHICH HEADQUARTERS IT AND
SUCH FOR EVERY- EVERY MEDIA
PURCHASE THAT WAS MADE I'D BE
HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE
TO PROVIDE MORE DETAILED ANSWER
ON THAT. THAT WOULD BE REALLY
GREAT SINCE WE'RE USING YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DOLLARS. TO
BRING MORE PEOPLE INTO
CALIFORNIA TO VISIT CALIFORNIA
WHICH WE CERTAINLY WOULD LIKE TO
YOU KNOW IN AN EFFORT FOR SAFE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY BUT I'M VERY
CURIOUS TO KNOW. IF THIS MONEY
IS ACTUALLY STAYING WITHIN THE
STATE OR IF I'S GOING TO.
ANOTHER STATE. PROBABLY LIKE NEW
YORK OR A DIFFERENT COMPANY IN
WHICH- IS NOT A- CALIFORNIA.
SUPPORTED COMPANY. SO BY THANK
YOU MY BE ABLE TO GET THAT DONE
TO THE CA. I THINK WE COULD
PROBABLY HAVE THEM WITHIN A
COUPLE OF WEEKS. OKAY WE'LL BE
SURE TO FOLLOW UP ON THAT AS
WELL. AT LAST YEAR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPERS IDENTIFY THE NEED TO
PROVIDE FUNDING TO SUPPORT
REGIONAL TOURISM RECOVERY
EFFORTS. IS THERE A PARTICULAR
REASON WHY THERE'S NO FUNDING
PROPOSAL FOR LOCAL AND REGIONAL
EFFORTS TO SUPPORT- TOURISM
RECOVERY. THE THERE IS A PLAN
TO. USE SOME OF OUR INDUSTRY
FUNDS TO DO SOME TERRORISM SOME
REGIONAL TOURISM PLANNING
EFFORTS IT'S A- PROCESS THAT WE
HOPE TO KICK OFF AT OUR BOARD
MEETING COMING UP HERE IN A
COUPLE WEEKS. OF THESE FUNDS-
THAT WERE ALLOCATED IN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET- WE- ARE KEEPING A
100% FOCUSED ON PAID MEDIA.
BECAUSE THAT IS WHAT WE CAN
MEASURE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF.
ONCE YOU START TO PULL APART
THOSE PAID MEDIA PURCHASES AND
USE THOSE FUNDS FOR OTHER THINGS
THE METHODOLOGY. AND IT JUST
DOESN'T REALLY EXIST TO TRACK
AFFECTED. MR CROSS ALL THOSE
DIFFERENT CHANNELS. THANK YOU
FOR THAT AND COMING SPEAK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE OUTREACH
EFFORT FOR THAT LOCAL-
SUPPORTING LOCAL REGIONAL
EFFORTS- IS THAT DONE IN. ONE
LANGUAGE OR MULTIPLE LANGUAGES.
IT'S JUST GETTING KICKED OFF THE
WITH A LISTENING SESSION WITH
OUR BOARD- IN- MID FEBRUARY- AND
THEN WE HOPE TO COME OUT OF THAT
PLAN. THAT WE HAD CONVERTED- ALL
OF OUR- OUTREACH- IN MULTI
MULTIPLE LANGUAGES. AND THAT
PROBABLY HAPPENED A FEW YEARS
AGO SO I WOULDN'T SEE ANY REASON
WE WOULDN'T DO. THE SAME THING
FOR THIS PROGRAM. DO YOU HAVE A
REPORT ON THE PAID MEDIA BY THAT
HAS ALREADY TAKEN PLACE IN TERMS
OF- LANGUAGES AND AUDIENCES THAT
RECEIVED. THAT OUTRAGE. IN TERMS
OF THE PAID MEDIA WHAT ARE YOU
ASKING WHAT CHANNELS IT WAS
TARGETED AT LIKE WHAT HAPPENS IS
. IT WAS IN TWO LANGUAGES
ENGLISH AND SPANISH AND I CAN
PROVIDE A MORE COMPLETE REPORT
OF- THE EXACT TARGET AUDIENCE
FOR EACH OF THOSE BIASES. THE
MEDIA PURCHASES ITSELF I MEAN
THOSE ARE ELABORATE AND THAT'S
WHY I DON'T HAVE A METHOD AND MY
FINGERTIPS THEY ARE- PAGES AND
PAGES LONG SO IT WILL TAKE US A
FEW DAYS TO PULL THAT TOGETHER
AND TELL YOU EXACTLY WHO THE
TARGET AUDIENCE WERE FOR EACH OF
THEM. BROADLY SPEAKING OUR
TARGETS ARE. ADULTS TWENTY FIVE
TO FIFTY FOUR DOMESTICALLY IN
THE TOP THIRD OF HOUSEHOLD
INCOME. I THINK THAT'S IS VERY
INTERESTING INFORMATION TO HAVE
CONSIDERING THE CALIFORNIA IS
ONE OF THE MORE. DIVERSE US
STATES IN THE NATION AND YOU NOT
ONLY DID. TELEVISION AND LINEAR
TV BUYS BUT YOU ALSO DID DIGITAL
AND SOCIAL. WHICH GIVES YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO MORE OUTREACH
OUTSIDE OF THE TWO LANGUAGES AND
I'M CURIOUS IF. YOU ONLY STEP A
PARTICULAR REASON WHY WAS ONLY
IN TWO LANGUAGES. OR IF THERE'S
AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO MORE- FOR
AN EFFORT OF INCREASING THAT
AUDIENCE BASE. CERTAINLY IT'S
SOMETHING WE LOOK AT WE'RE WE'RE
DRIVEN BY EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
MARKETING STRATEGY- I THINK IT'S
WORTH NOTING THAT OUR EFFORTS
ARE FOCUSED PRIMARILY ON OUT OF
STATE YEAH WITH THE INTENT TO
DRIVE INBOUND TRAVEL TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO IT'S A
NET ECONOMIC BENEFIT TO THE
STATE. WE DIDN'T DO IN AGAIN
DURING PANDEMIC TIMES WE DID DO
SOME IN STATE ADVERTISING AND
THAT'S WHERE YOU SAW THE SPANISH
LANGUAGE MEDIA REALLY COME-
BECOME IN THAT BEAT BE VERY
HELPFUL WHEN WE WERE TRYING TO
KEEP TRAVELERS CALIFORNIANS- TO
VACATION THEIR BACKYARD FOR TWO
REASONS ONE IT WAS SAFER SAFER
FROM A PUBLIC HEALTH RISK. INTO
A PREVENTED THE DOLLARS FROM
LEAVING THE STATE REVERSING A
LOT OF WHAT WE CALL A TRAVEL
LEAKAGE TO THE TUNE OF ABOUT A
BILLION DOLLARS A MONTH- IN LATE
TWENTY TWENTY IN EARLY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WERE CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS WERE LEAVING
CALIFORNIA GOING TO ARIZONA
GOING TO OTHER STATES. FOR THEIR
VACATION SO WE DID EXIST IN SOME
OF THAT FUNDING SOME OF THOSE
MEDIA DOLLARS TO TRY TO CAPTURE
AS MUCH BACK CALIFORNIA
ATTENTION AS WE COULD AGAIN FOR
THOSE TWO MAIN REASONS HEALTH
REASON AND ECONOMIC. DEVELOPMENT
RECENT. I THANK YOU FOR THAT I
WOULD SAY THAT THE SOUND
SLIGHTLY CON. CONSIDERING THAT
ONE OF THE- ONE OF THE POINTS
THAT WE BROUGHT UP IN LAST
YEAR'S HEARING RELATED TO PUBLIC
HEALTH IS THAT WE WOULD
POTENTIALLY BE BRINGING IN.
FOLKS TO CALIFORNIA FROM OTHER
STATES THAT WERE UNVACCINATED.
AND SO. TO SAY THAT SOMEONE IN
LOS ANGELES FOR EXAMPLE WOULD
AND TRAVEL TO TOPPLE. AT TO
VACATION WITH THEIR FAMILY
VERSUS SOMEBODY FROM TEXAS
COMING TO CALIFORNIA TO GO TO AN
AMUSEMENT PARK- SEEMS KIND OF
CONTRADICTORY BECAUSE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA'S LARGE
GOOD FOR MULTIPLE STATES IN
CALIFORNIA YOU CAN BE IN SAN
DIEGO AND NEVER TRAVEL TO SAN
FRANCISCO YOU COULD BE. AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND NEVER HAVE
GONE TO- OF SAN DIEGO OR OTHER
PARTS OF THE STATE WHILE STILL
KEEPING THOSE DOLLARS WITHIN
CALIFORNIA. WHICH IS STILL AN
ISSUE WITH PUBLIC HEALTH AND
FOLKS IN CALIFORNIA BEING
VACCINATED VERSUS BRINGING IN
OTHER DOLLARS FROM OTHER STATES
AND POTENTIALLY CAUSING A RISK
OF ADDITIONAL- CONTAMINATION BY
THE VIRUS. WHICH IS WHY I'M
JORDY OF OUR MEDIA BY WAS REALLY
POSITION FOR AFTER THE STATE WAS
REOPENED TO TRAVEL WE WORKED IN
CLOSE COORDINATION WITH CDPH
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE WE CAN AND
WE CONTINUE TO DO SO THROUGHOUT
THE ENTIRE PANDEMIC- TO MAKE
SURE THAT WHAT WE WERE SAYING-
FROM THE- FROM THE PLATFORM OF
INSPIRING TRAVEL WITHIN INTO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WAS NOT AT
ODDS WITH WHAT PUBLIC HEALTH WAS
TRYING TO DO AS WELL SO. THE
DAILY IF NOT MORE FREQUENTLY
THAN THAT CALLS WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES AT CDPH TO DO JUST
THAT. YEAH WOULD YOU BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE- THE- WITH THEM MAYBE A
FOLDER DROPBOX FOLDER AS A
SAMPLE OF THE MEDIA ADDS THAT WE
HAVE NOTHING. I'D VERY IS TO
LOOK AT WHAT YOU'VE DONE FOR
LINEAR ONLINE DIGITAL- AND WHAT
THAT A LOT OF STATE MARKETING
LOOKS LIKE- IN BOTH LANGUAGES
THAT YOU CURRENTLY HAVE DONE.
ABSOLUTELY GREAT THANK YOU SO
WILL RESPECT THAT IN A FEW WEEKS
ALONG WITH THE REPORT US TO.
VICE MEDIA AND WHERE THAT
FUNDING WENT TO. YES GREAT ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS FROM THE
MEMBERS. MISTER COOPER. TO
FOLLOW UP ON THAT MEASURE
QUESTION EARLY ON ASSETS CAN THE
EXCESS ASSETS BE USED FOR THE
SAME PURPOSE REQUEST IN THE BCP
. YES M. AND WE ARE ACTIVELY
SPENDING DOWN THOSE ASSETS NOW
ALONG WITH THE STATE PROVIDED
FUNDING. OKAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISER COOPER WE CAN AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH TO THE
PANELISTS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO- ARE ISSUE NUMBER THREE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ISSUE NUMBER
THREE IS IMMIGRATION INTEGRATION
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT THIS IS
MISS EMILY DECIDE ON THE LONG I
HOPE I SAID THAT CORRECTLY. YES
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU EMELIE
DECIDE. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ONLY DECIDE I SERVE AS
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
INTERNATIONAL AFFAIRS AND TRADE
TEAM AT GO THIS GENERATIONS OF
IMMIGRANTS AROUND THE GLOBE HAVE
SHAPED CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY AND
PROGRESS TODAY IMMIGRANTS
COMPRISE 27% OF OUR STATE
POPULATION WELL HALF OF ALL
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA HAVE AT
LEAST ONE IMMIGRANT PARENTS.
IT'S WHETHER THEY ARRIVE TO SEEK
SAFETY OR OPPORTUNITY. ALL
CALIFORNIA'S IDENTITY AND
ECONOMIC GROWTH FOR MULTIPLE
GENERATIONS AND CALIFORNIA HAS
BEEN A NATIONAL LEADER IN
DEVELOPING POLICIES AND PROGRAMS
AIM TO SUPPORT OUR STATE'S
DIVERSE IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY
PARTICULARLY TO ADDRESS
DISPARITIES IN ACCESS TO HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AND TO
ENHANCE CRITICAL LABOR AND
WORKFORCE PROTECTIONS. EXPANDING
THIS EXPERTISE WITHIN THE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
INTERNATIONAL PORTFOLIO AT KOBE
IS THE NEXT CHAPTER ON
CALIFORNIA'S PROGRESS TO ADVANCE
IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION IN EQUITY
WITH THAT IN MIND WE ARE
REQUESTING ELEVEN POINT SIX
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE.
AND FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ANNUALLY THEREAFTER FOR THIS
PROPOSAL WHICH SERVES TWO
PRIMARY FUNCTIONS FIRST IT AIMS
TO ADDRESS GAPS IN RESOURCES TO
SUPPORT STATEWIDE CONVENING IN
COORDINATION THROUGH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE THAT IS
POPULATION FOCUSED ACROSS THE
PORTFOLIOS OF OUR STATE AGENCY
PARTNERS. IMMIGRATION EVENTS IN
RECENT YEARS HAVE HIGHLIGHTED
THE BENEFITS AND IMPORTANCE OF
COORDINATION ACROSS STATE
GOVERNMENT TO SUPPORT EFFECTIVE
RESPONSE. INTERNATIONAL AFFAIRS
AND TRADE HIM ALREADY PLAYS A
UNIQUE ROLE AS A CONVENER THE
STATE INCLUDING ON ISSUES TO THE
BORDER AND OTHER INTERNET
AFFAIRS AND IS WELL POSITIONED
TO SUPPORT STATEWIDE
COORDINATION ON IMMIGRATION
EXPERTISE ACROSS GOVERNMENT
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES. SECONDS
THIS PROPOSAL BUILT ON THE STATE
INVESTMENT IN ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY. FOR
ENTREPRENEURSHIP. IT DOES THIS
THROUGH ONE TIME FOR LOCAL GUY
TO HELL CITIES AND COUNTIES SEAT
INTO PLAY BEST PRACTICES AND
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES FOR
IMMIGRANT ENTREPRENEURS AND
BUSINESS OWNERS. CREATING
ACCESSIBLE AND TAILORED BUSINESS
START GUIDES IN MULTIPLE
LANGUAGES AND SUPPORTS BUSINESS
GROWTH AND RESILIENCY STRATEGIES
THROUGH EXPORT TRAINING AND
CROSS BORDER ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. THANK YOU AND I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU BEFORE WE GO ON TO THE
L. A. O. AND TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE WE'RE GOING TO DO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM CAN WE TAKE
ROLL CALL PLEASE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CREW HERE SAM ROBERT
COOPER THEY'RE FAMILY MEMBER
LACKEY HERE ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN
THIS AREA. SAM AND I'M WICKS.
ALL RIGHT LET'S CONTINUE THANK
YOU SO MUCH- LET'S HEAR FROM
SOMEBODY BEFORE WE GO TO THE
DIETS THAT SEE US SOMEBODY FROM
DELEO MISTER WEATHERFORD. YES HI
YES THIS IS BRIAN WITH THE FOR
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND FROM WHAT I'M GOING. TO MISS
MY COMMENTS THE EIGHT POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLAR- ONE TIME-
GRANT PROGRAM FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. SO I THINK OUR
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS FIRMEST IS
DONE ON- BUT SOME OF THE DETAILS
SEEM TO BE FULLY DEVELOP YET AND
SPECIFICALLY- WE'RE NOT REALLY
SURE HOW THE PROGRAM ADDRESSES
SPECIFIC BARRIERS TO STARTING
AND GROWING A BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA YOU NEED TO
IMMIGRANTS. AND- HE THE SPECIFIC
RETURN THAT THE BIDS USED TO THE
GRANT. ARE IS THERE'S A LOT. AND. THERE SHOULD BE. SOME OF
REPORT REQUIRED TO VALUE WHETHER
THE PER THAT ARE. THANK YOU AS
SOMEONE THE OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR TO PARK TOMORROW
JOHNSON DEPARTMENT OF FOR- JUST
TO- ADDRESS THE L. A. COMES
ABOUT- AT THE SPECIFICS TO THE
GRANT PRO- WE ARE OPEN TO MAKE
CPAS. ON THE GRANTS- IN BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE- SO WE CAN WORK
WITH- YOUR STAFF TO- DRAFT WITH
THAT WOULD LOOK LIKE. IS THERE
ALREADY TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
FOR THIS PROPOSAL. AND THERE IS
CURRENTLY NO- TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE DRAFTED OR PROPOSED-
BUT WE ARE OPEN TO- THOSE
DISCUSSIONS OR INCLUDING- AND
SPECIFICS ON THE ON THE GRANT
PROGRAM IN BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
. THAT WOULD BE CRITICAL FOR ANY
EARLY ACTION TO HAVE THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE READY TO GO. NO
NOT PRIORITY. ALL RIGHT SKEWS ME
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. GOT IT EXCUSE
MY COMMENTS THIS IS NOT SLATED
FOR EARLY ACTION BUT STILL WOULD
BE IMPORTANT TO SEE IF WE CAN
FIGURE THAT PIECE OUT AT THE L.
A. O. COMMENTS INCLUDE A NUMBER
OF KEY QUESTIONS THAT I BELIEVE
ARE IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTANDING
THIS PCP IF YOU COULD ANSWER. UP
WHAT YOU BELIEVE ARE THE KEY
BARRIERS TO ECONOMIC INTEGRATION
FOR IMMIGRANTS AND HOW- HOW DOES
THE PROGRAM OUTLINED IN THE B.
C. PEOPLE ADDRESS THOSE BARRIERS
. YOU FOR THE QUESTION CHAIR-
CALIFORNIA HAS REMOVED
DOCUMENTATION BARRIERS TO
STARTING A BUSINESS AND INVESTED
IN MICROGRAMS LIMITED. ENGLISH
PROFICIENT ENTREPRENEURS. THIS
PROPOSAL COMPLEMENTS THOSE
EFFORTS WITH ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES AT AN ESPECIALLY
CRITICAL MOMENT- DESPITE THEIR
PURPOSE. FOR ENTREPRENEURSHIP WE
KNOW THAT IMMIGRANTS FACE
CERTAIN. HURDLES TO STARTING
SUSTAINING AND GROWING THEIR OWN
BUSINESSES- SO THERE A NUMBER OF
KEY BARRIERS I WOULD POINT TO-
THAT IMMIGRANTS WHO PER. FACE
ACCESS TO CAPITAL TO STARTED.
NOT FOR AND LOCAL RESOURCES THAT
PROMOTE ENTREPRENEURSHIP. NOW
STATE AND LOCAL PROCEDURES FOR
STARTING A BUSINESS INCLUDING
ACCESS TO RESOURCES AND
CULTURALLY COMPETENT NATIVE
LANGUAGES. SO THIS PROPOSAL
WOULD ADDRESS THOSE BARRIERS IN
IN SEVERAL WAYS- WITH PRETTY.
AND ON ON THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
GRANT FUNDING. PROVIDING FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO EXPAND
THEIR SERVICE PROVISION TO
IMMIGRANT BUSINESS OWNERS AND
ENTREPRENEURS. WE FEEL IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT WELL WE
WELCOME OF COURSE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE CONTINUED
DISCUSSION WITH THIS COMMITTEE
AND WITH OUR PARTNERS THE
LEGISLATURE. CRAFT THE CRITERIA
FOR THIS PROGRAM WHAT WE WOULD
EMPHASIZES. WE WANTED TO KEEP
FLEXIBILITY YOU PROGRAM DESIGNED
SO THAT LOCAL COMMUNITIES THAT
SERVE THESE IMMIGRANT
ENTREPRENEURS AND SERVE THE
COMMUNITIES. WOULD REALLY HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TAILOR THE
PROGRAM FOR WHAT'S MOST
APPROPRIATE FOR THEIR REGION.
THAT SAID WE WOULD CERTAINLY
INCORPORATE KEY CRITERIA FOR
FUNDING. SO THAT WOULD INCLUDE
THINGS LIKE REQUIRING
SOLICITATION AND RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS AND
SERVICE PROVIDERS. THAT
REPRESENTATIVE DEMOGRAPHICS OF
THE IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES IN
THOSE AREAS- WE WOULD PROPOSE
USING- DOLLARS CAME. ALIGNMENT
WITH THE NEEDS OF IMMIGRANT
POPULATIONS IN THE REGION- WE
WOULD WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT.
JURISDICTION'S WHO HAVE A
CRITICAL NEEDS RELATED TO
SUPPORTING NEW COVER
POPULATIONS. ARE ALSO ABLE TO.
ACCESS FUNDING AND SEE IT AND
DEVELOP AND DEPLOY BEST
PRACTICES. FOR IMMIGRANT
SERVICES. WHAT WITH REGARD TO
THE OTHER THING THE I WOULD
MENTION IS MY TEAM INTERNET
AFFAIRS AND TRADE. DISPATCHED TO
REQUIRE TO SEE AN ANNUAL TO THE
- EACH- SO WITH APPROACH LIKE
THIS THAT WOULD UPS. BE THAT
WOULD BE IN IN THAT PUBLICLY.
REPORT AND ASK IS DOES WITH
OTHER PROGRAMS- THAT WE
ADMINISTER FROM THE GRANT
PERSPECTIVE WE WOULD BE MORE
THAN HAPPY TO PROVIDE REGULAR
UPDATES TO THIS COMMITTEE AND
EVER ELSE YOU DESIGNATE. ON THE
DESIGN OF THE PROGRAM AND THEN
RESULT AS THEIR GENERATED. HAS
THE PROGRAM DEVELOPS. THANK YOU
THAT SAID THAT CERTAINLY A LOT
OF- IT'S A BIG BIG GOALS TO
ACCOMPLISH AND I'M CURIOUS. THE
FUNDING PROPOSAL SUGGESTED THAT
ON THAT ADDING ONE PERSON I'D GO
BUSINESS. TO SUPPORT A STATEWIDE
COORDINATION AND DIRECT
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT. IMMIGRANT
INTEGRATION THIS LEVEL OF
STAFFING SEEMS INSUFFICIENT TO
WHAT YOU JUST LAID OUT. OR TO
MAKE MEANINGFUL IMPROVEMENTS.
HOW DID GO VISIT TURMAN THE
SCOPE AND FUNDING FOR THESE
ACTIVITIES. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION SHARE THE ONE POSITION
I THINK WOULD REALLY BE A
POSITION TO EXPAND UPON THE
SERVICES THAT ARE ALREADY IN
PLACE AND MANY OF OTHER STATE
PARTNERS. SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
IMMIGRATION INTEGRATION WEKNOW
THAT IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA FACE A RANGE
OF NEEDS AND SERVICES SO THIS
POSITION WOULD REALLY BE FOCUSED
ON PROVIDING FOR THAT
COORDINATION. WITH DEPARTMENTS
LIKE LABOR AND WORKFORCE WITHIN
D. A DSS AND OTHERS THAT HAVE
ALREADY IMMIGRANT FOCUSED
POSITIONS THAT ARE SERVING
COMMUNITIES BUT THE PARTICULAR
EXPERTISE THAT THE STATE
AGENCIES. SO VERY MUCH TO YOUR
POINT WE WOULDN'T PRESUME THAT
THIS ONE POSITION WOULD BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE ENTIRETY OF
IT BUT WOULD REALLY BE FOCUSED
ON COORDINATION- ACROSS STATE
AGENCY PARTNERS WITH DIFFERENT
LEVELS OF. EXPERTISE AND CORE
SERVICE PROVISION AND I THINK
IMPORTANTLY WHERE THIS PERSON
WOULD ADD- IMPORTANT-
CONTRIBUTIONS WOULD BE.
COORDINATING WITH LOCAL PARTNERS
ON THE DISTRIBUTION OF FUNDS IN
CONCERT AND IN COLLABORATION
WITH WITH STATE AGENCY PARTNERS.
FOR THANK YOU FOR THAT I ONE M.
I HAVE ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS BUT
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THEY GIVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO THE MEMBERS OF
THE DIGEST DOESN'T QUICKLY I'M-
I'M HAVING A HARD TO I'M- I'M
NOT. TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
WHAT IS BEEN THE FOCUS OF THE
STATE FUNDED TRADE MISSIONS. YES
THANK YOU FOR THAT THE QUESTIONS
ARE SO- WE STRONGLY BELIEVE.
THAT I. ARE KEY LIE. IN REVENUES
. OPPORTUNITY SMALL BUSINESSES
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT MY TEAM
HAS EXPERTISE IN- WE PROVIDE A
SUPPORT FOR SMALL BUSINESSES
ACROSS THE STATE SO THEY CAN TAP
INTO THAT 95% OF CONSUMERS THAT
WE KNOW ARE NOT IN THE UNITED
STATES. SO TRADE MISSIONS ARE
REALLY GEARED TOWARD PROVIDING
THOSE TRANSACTIONAL COMMERCIAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES- THAT MIGHT NOT
OTHERWISE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TAKE ON THAT. ABOUT GLOBAL
ENGAGEMENT AND WE'VE REALLY
PROVIDE THAT THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
THEM TO ENGAGE DIRECTLY WITH
THOSE BUYERS. WE DO SO HAND IN
HAND WITH THE U. S. COMMERCIAL
SERVICE- AND OTHER PARTNERS TO
HELP US TO IDENTIFY. OVERSEAS
OPPORTUNITIES SO FOR EXAMPLE IN
THE PAST YEAR AND A HALF MY TEAM
IS PUT TOGETHER TEN. TRADE
MISSIONS FOR MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED SMALL BUSINESSES- WE
PROVIDED A SMALL BUSINESSES
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FOREIGN
PROCUREMENT CONTRACTS FOR YOU
KNOW NEW BUSINESS VENTURES TO
SELL THEIR PRODUCTS AND THEIR
SERVICES OVERSEAS. SO THE TRADE
MISSION ASPECT IS REALLY A WAY
FOR US TO HELP. MITIGATE THE
RISK OF THOSE SMALL BUSINESSES
AS THEY TAKE ON THAT NEW
OPPORTUNITY. MY TEAM IS A MEMBER
OF THE STATE INTERNATIONAL
DEVELOPMENT ORGANIZATION
RECITAL. BUT THE NATIONAL ARM
THAT THAT BRINGS TOGETHER ME AND
MY COUNTERPARTS. 88% OF THEIR
MEMBERS OR THIRTY SIX U. S.
STATES SUPPORT TRADE. MISSIONS
FOR SMALL BUSINESSES. MY UP MY
CONCERN IT'S NOT A HUGE BECAUSE
IT'S NOT A HUGE OF MONEY IT IS
A- AMOUNT. IS THAT- I AND- I'M
BELIEVING THAT OF THE US SMALL
BUSINESS ADMINISTRATION WHICH IS
FEDERAL MONEY. AS PRIMARILY THE
SUPPORTER OF SUCH A PROGRAM IS
THERE TRULY A NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDING. I APPRECIATE
THAT QUESTION ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LACKEY- I WOULD SAY YES- BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA IS SO LARGE MYTEAM
DOES WORK ON THAT SB A PROGRAM
THE STATE TRADE EXPANSION
PROGRAM THAT YOU REFERENCE- AT
THIS POINT THE GRANT IS DOES NOT
MEET THE DEMANDS OF THE FOUR
POINT FIVE MILLION SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT OPERATE IN OUR
STATE. SO WE FEEL CONFIDENT THAT
THE ADDITIONAL- ALBEIT SMALL
AMOUNT OF GENERAL FUNDS WITH
SUPPLEMENT AND MEET THAT DEMAND
THAT OUR SMALL BUSINESS
COMMUNITY IS REALLY PRESENTING
AND WOULD REALLY SERVE TO
AUGMENT- THIS FEDERAL FUNDS THAT
WE ALSO EFFECTIVELY DEPLOY. AND
MATHIS AYE THOSE THOSE BUSINESS
THERE'S OF RIGHT NOW- WOULD
RESULT WITH REGARD TO THE TRADE
PARTNERSHIP ARE THE IMMIGRANT.
WE WORK WITH BUSINESS NOT
BUSINESSES OF ALL TYPES I MEAN
WE SIR- PRAYER WOMEN AND BETTER
AND MINORITY- OWNED BUSINESSES-
SO WE WOULD WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE PROVIDING THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO UNDERSERVED
BUSINESSES ACROSS THE STATE.
THAT DOESN'T ANSWER MY QUESTION
ARE THEY IMMIGRANT BUSINESSES.
YES MA'AM THERE ARE IMMIGRANT
THEIR IMMIGRANT BUSINESSES ARE
INCLUDED IN IN OUR SERVICES AND
OUR PROGRAMS WE DON'T HAVE EXACT
DATA TO TELL YOU HOW MANY. BUT
YES. WHEN CAN YOU PROVIDE THAT
DATA SO THAT WE HAVE A
PERCENTAGE AS TO WHICH HOW MANY
OF THESE SMALL BUSINESSES ARE
ACTUALLY IMMIGRANT OWNED
BUSINESSES. I CAN FOLLOW UP WITH
YOU AND SEE HOW WE CAN PROVIDE
THE INFORMATION FOR YOU. OKAY
CAN WE HAVE A TIME LINE AS TOWHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE OR WOULD
YOU BE REACHING OUT TO COMMITTEE
STAFF AND THEN DETERMINE THE
TURNING THAT. I WOULD BE
REACHING OUT TO COMMITTEE STAFF
TO DETERMINE THAT MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU- MEXICO TO YOUR POINT
ABOUT TRADES MEXICO IS
CONSISTENTLY ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S
TOP TRADING PARTNERS A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND ONGOING.
GENERAL FUNDS. A SEEM IN SOME
FISH INSUFFICIENT TO ENHANCE THE
BORDER REGION ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT ACTIVITIES AND
GROWING. BILATERAL TRADE AND
INVESTMENTS BETWEEN CALIFORNIA
AND MEXICO HOW DID GO VISIT
TURMAN THE SCOPE AND FUNDING FOR
THESE ACTIVITIES AND THOSE GO
BIZ. BELIEVE THAT THIS FUNDING
LEVEL IS SUFFICIENT. TO ADDRESS
THE PRIORITIES. ALREADY APPROVED
BY THE LEGISLATURE WE HAVE S. B.
SIX EIGHTY FOUR- BY SENATOR WEST
SO IN SB FIVE FIVE EIGHT ALSO BY
SENATOR. WAS SO WHICH- PAST THAT
IN THE LEGISLATURE BUT WAS
VETOED IN TWENTY NINETEEN. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AYE AYE THAT
FUNDING THAT WE'VE REQUESTED FOR
IT THESE TRADE MISSIONS BUT I
THINK SPEAKS TO SEVERAL THINGS-
HAVING DONE TEN- TRADE MISSIONS
THIS PAST YEAR AND A HALF THAT
HAVE BEEN. BOB RITUAL WE KNOW
THE APPROXIMATE COST OF
EXECUTING THESE TRADE MISSIONS
SO THIS HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND WOULD ALLOW US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EXECUTE BETWEEN
FOUR AND FIVE TRADE MISSIONS
SUCH BASED ON NOT ON THE DATA.
OF THE TRADE MISSIONS THAT WE'VE
ALREADY PROVIDED FOR THE PAST
YEAR AND A HALF- SO YOU KNOW WE
REALLY SEE THIS AND I THINK
THAT'S ALSO CONNECTS TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LACKEYS QUESTION. THIS
WOULD BE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US
DEPARTMENT FEDERAL FUNDS FOR
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT TRADE
PARTNER AND TO REALLY PROMOTE
THE CROSS BORDER ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT THAT WE ARE ON VERY
MUCH COMMITTED TO WITH OUR MOST
IMPORTANT TRADE PARTNER. OKAY
WELL WE'LL FOLLOW UP ON THIS ONE
AS WELL IN TERMS OF NOT SURE I
GOT THE ANSWER AS TO. HOW GO
BIZ- BELIEVE THAT IF THE
SPENDING A SUFFICIENT. TO
DETERMINE THESE GOALS. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR THAT THAT HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND WOULD ALLOW
US TO COMPLETE FOUR TO FIVE
TRADE MISSIONS- OVER THE COURSE
OF THE NEXT YEAR SHOULD THE
FUNDING BE APPROVED- YOU KNOW
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT OUR
TEAM HAS THE CAPACITY TO DELIVER
ON WITH HER PARTNERS- SO FROM A
STAFFING PERSPECTIVE WE KNOW
THAT IT TAKES QUITE A BIT OF
WORK TO EXECUTE THESE TRADE
MISSIONS TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ARE- A BENEFIT. AND GOOD USE OF
THE SMALL BUSINESS TIME THAT WE
ASKED TO PARTICIPATE IN THEM SO
EXECUTING FORTIFIED TRADE
MISSIONS WITH THIS FUNDING IN
ADDITION TO THE REST OF THE
PLANS THAT WE HAVE FOR THE
COURSE OF THE YEAR- IS BASED ON
THAT THE COST OF WHAT WE KNOW
THESE TRADE MISSIONS HAVE BEEN
IN THE PAST AND ALSO THE
CAPACITY OF US TO DELIVER ON
THESE FORTY FIVE TRADE MISSIONS
IN ADDITION TO OUR OTHER
PRIORITIES FOR THE YEAR. OKAY
THANK YOU FOR THAT- BEFORE WITH
A MOVE ON TO THE NEXT- PANEL. ON
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT I JUST
WANT TO STRESS THE IMPORTANCE OF
HAVING TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
AVAILABLE SOONER RATHER THAN
LATER. THERE ARE SOME PRIORITIES
THAT I'M THINKING ABOUT WHEN
LOOKING AT THIS PROGRAM. ABSENT
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE I CAN'T
DETERMINE I'M NOT SURE MY
COLLEAGUES CAN EITHER. GIVE
THESE PRIORITIES- WILL BE MET-
I'LL JUST LAY SOME OF THESE OUT.
SOME OF THESE PRIORITIES INCLUDE
BILL BUILDING OUT KEY STAFF
WITHIN GO BIZ TO SUPPORT
STATEWIDE COORDINATION AND
IMPORTANCE. FIRST THEY LET
CALIFORNIA HOME TO THE LARGEST
POPULATION OF IMMIGRANTS
INCLUDING THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN.
RESIDENTS FOR YEARS OR DECADES.
THIS POSITION WILL BE A KEY
PARTNER IN CONVENING. ACROSS
AGENCIES TO ENSURE SUCCESS OF
THESE PROGRAMS AND COMMUNITIES.
ADDITIONALLY FOCUSING ON ENGLISH
LANGUAGE TRAINING LANGUAGE
ACCESS OVERALL AND RESOURCES
RELATED TO CITIZENSHIP WOULD BE
HELPFUL TO WORK- CALIFORNIA HAS
ALREADY INTO THE WORK THAT
CALIFORNIA'S ALREADY INVESTED
IN. ACROSS DEPARTMENTS AND
AGENCIES ESPECIALLY THOSE AIMED
AT LEGAL SERVICES. AND LASTLY
PROVIDING GRANT MONEY FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO CREATE OR FURTHER
THEIR OWN. IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION
WORK WITH LOCAL WITH A LOCAL
LANDS. AT IS A VERY. IMPORTANT
AND CRITICAL COMPONENT. NOT
EVERY CITY OR COUNTY INVEST IN
THIS WORK. OR HAS THE RESOURCES
TO INVEST IN THE SAME WAY THESE
DOLLARS HELP CREATE. BRIDGES TO
THIS WORK THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
LEVELS THAT. FITS THE SPECIFICS
OF A LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND SO
AGAIN I WANT TO STRESS THE
IMPORTANCE OF HAVING. TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE US SOONER RATHER
THAN LATER. THANK YOU ALL SO
MUCH OF THERE ARE NO ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS WE CAN A LOT. OKAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER FOUR-
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT- MISS
GRAY ARE YOU ON THE LINE. YES I
AM NOT A CHANCE OKAY LET'S BEGIN
- THANK YOU I'M ASKED HEARD. A
LARGE A PROPOSAL TO RETELL CRAFT
HELLO WE ARE REQUESTING TWENTY
MILLION- THAT FOR A GRANT
PROGRAM FOR SMALL BUSINESSES A
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT AND RETAIL
TO DEVELOP THIS PROGRAM WE
ANTICIPATE THAT THE PROGRAM
WOULD SIMPLY COMPENSATE SMALL
BUSINESSES FOR PROPERTY LOSSES
AS A RESULT CRYING. OUT WE HOPE
TO HAVE TRAILER BILL- LANGUAGE
AVAILABLE I THE NEXT FEW WEEKS.
THANK YOU I'LL LET SOMEONE OPEN
IT UP BOB BEFORE WE ACTUALLY GO
TO THE DIS- ANY. MISTER
WEATHERFORD FROM THE ALEJO'S
OFFICE ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
. YES AS AS THE MISCREANT NOTED
THIS PROPOSAL IS PART OF A
LARGER ORGANIZED RETAIL PACKAGE
- AND- OUR OFFICES. COMMENT IS
THAT YOU SHOULD CONSIDER WHETHER
THE GOAL OF THIS PROPOSAL IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE
LEGISLATURE'S BROADER PUBLIC
SAFETY GOALS SO FOR EXAMPLE THIS
PROPOSALS INTENDED TO PROVIDE
VICTIM COMPENSATION AND DOESN'T
DIRECTLY ADDRESS PUBLIC SAFETY.
SO AS YOU IN THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER HOW TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEM OF ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT TO WANT TO CONSIDER
WHETHER THE GOALS OF THIS
PROPOSAL OUR ENVIRONMENT WITH
YOUR PARTICLES. AND THEN GETTING
TO THE DETAILS OF THIS PROPOSAL
THERE'S- NOT A LOT OF- DETAILS
ACTUALLY. BUT KNOW IF THERE'S
NUMBER OF PRESS CAN. THAT COULD
MAKE ESTABLISHING PROPOSED
PROGRAM QUITE CHALLENGING. AND-
WE THOSE ARE THOSE THE MOST IN
YOUR AGENDA- BUT WE'RE TO
DISCUSS THE FOR THE PEOPLE.
THANK YOU IS THERE. ANY COMMONER
. FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. TOMORROW JOHNSON DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NOTHING I HAD. THANK YOU
I'M ACTUALLY REALLY EXCITED THAT
WE HAVE TO FORMER LAW
ENFORCEMENT. OFFICERS HERE ON
THE DIETS AND WANT TO OPEN IT UP
TO YOU AS WELL TO ANY QUESTIONS
MISTER MISTER COOPER SURE THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I DELEON
SOME COMMENTS SEVERAL PRACTICAL
CONSIDERATIONS MUST BE ADDRESSED
. REALLY THE BIG THING IS. THE
MONEY WHO THEY GO TO WE TALK
ABOUT SMASHING GRABBED THE CALL
THE SMASH AND GRABS MOST OF
THOSE HAVE BEEN A HIGH END
RETAILERS LEAVE A TOTS BURBERRY
I MEAN THE BIG HIGH END
RETAILERS BUT TALK ABOUT SMALL
BUSINESS SO THERE'S A DISCONNECT
BETWEEN WHAT A SMALL BUSINESS IN
THE HIGH END RETAILERS WHO'S
ELIGIBLE WHAT DO YOU PROVE WHAT
DO YOU DO. THIS WAS A BIG
CONCERN DOES GO BIZ REALLY HAVE
THE INSTITUTIONAL EXPERIENCE. A
INCLUDING A PROGRAM LIKE THIS
AND THAT'S FROM THE BIG CONCERNS
WHAT'S L. ELIGIBILITY SO JUST TO
WHOLE MYRIAD OF ISSUES. AND EVEN
THOUGH THE SMASH AND GRAB HAVE
GOTTEN. THE MAJORITY OF THE-
ATTENTION ATTENTION PICKING
MEASURE ATTENTION- THOSE FOLKS
HAVE INSURANCE SO WHEN I THINK
SMALL BIZ LIKE MOM AND POP SHOPS
A SMALL CORNER MARKET IN A
NEIGHBORHOOD WHERE SOMEBODY
WALKS IN THERE AND GRABS UP
HANDS FULL AMPLE THE FOOD OR
ALCOHOL AND WALKS OUT THEY CAN'T
REPLACE THAT THOSE ONES ARE
TRULY BEING IMPACTED THE MOST.
YOU KNOW WE WE'VE SEEN FOLKS
WHAT RABBI IN THE CVS OR
WALGREENS AND HAVE A BIG PLASTIC
TRASH BAGS LOADED UP AND WRITE
OUT A THERE ARE A LOT OF- BALLS
IN THE AIR ON THIS AND REALLY
THE GOVERNOR'S FOR A LOT OF
MONEY TOWARDS THIS- FILING THE
MONEY'S GOING TOWARDS LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT. BUT THE BIG ISSUE
IS THE LAW IS THE LAW IT HAS NOT
CHANGED FOR RETAIL ORGANIZED
CRIME TO REALLY DEAL WITH THIS
AND THINK ABOUT THIS HE BUILT ON
A LOT OF MONEY AT IT- IF I THINK
TO MAKE EVERYBODY FEEL GOOD BUT
TO REST SOMEONE FOR ORGANIZED
RETAIL CRIME AND CHARGE THEM.
YES BEYOND THE THIRD CONVICTION
YOU HAVE TO PROVE THAT IT WAS
FOR THE PURPOSES OF RESELL SO
SOMEONE HAS TO ADMIT THEY'RE
GONNA RESELL THAT PROPERTY
NUMBER ONE AND NUMBER TWO IF TO
PROVE CONSPIRACY NO ONE EVER
PROVED CONSPIRACY ON STAFFS-
THINK ABOUT THAT WITH NEW
CHARGES PERCY ON SOMEONE TO BE
FOR THE MURDER CASE WE HAVE
SOMEONE ON TAPE RECORDING TYPE
RECORDING. A THING THEY'RE DOING
THAT SO IT'S VERY VERY HARD TO
CHARGE IF YOU LOOK AT THIS LAWS. BEEN EFFECT FOR TWO YEARS NOW.
LOOK AT THE NUMBER OF A-
ACTUALLY CHARGED IMPROV. OF THE
RETAIL FOR CRIME LAW. WE DID
SOME P. R. A. IT IS VERY.
BECAUSE THIS MUCH THE- MOST U.
DA LECTURE. BECAUSE TO HARD TO
PROVE IN THAT CRIME SO- JUST FOR
GOBIZ I GUESS I MEAN. YOU GUYS
DON'T HAVE THE EXPERTISE AND-
YOU KNOW ASK THIS QUESTION LAST
WEEK WHEN WE HAD HE FULL BUDGET
SUB COMMITTEE- YES FULL BUDGET
HEARING. AND WE STILL KNOW THE
DEFINITION OF A SMALL BUSINESS
SO I MEAN. TO ME A LOT OF
QUESTIONS THAT. NEED TO BE
ANSWERED. BEFORE THIS PROGRAM
GIVE. IN LET'S BE HONEST THAT
THE BID FOLKS LIKE. SOME DARK
WALMART WITH FOLKS- GONNA FIGURE
OUT PUTS INTO TO GET THE MONEY.
IT'S GOT BE SMALL BUSINESS BUT
WE THOUGHT NO DEFINITE OF SMALL. SO HOW YOU GONNA DO AGO.
DURING THE GROUND HERE- DO YOU
POINT- AS THE MEMBER COOPER THE
LARGE RETAILERS I'M WHICH HAVE
BEENIN THE- HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
ISSUE WITH THE RETAIL- BUT THE
PROBLEM IS AS- FOR SMALL BIZ
THAT AND ON THE ON THE A WEST A
THOSE BUSINESS VERY WELL- FOR
THE PURPOSES THIS. WE ARE LOOK
AT SMALL TELL OUT- WITH FIGHTING%
. DOLLARS IN ANNUAL REVENUE LAST
I'M IN WE FRANK WANT DO WITH
THAT I THAT SOME ONE STAND CAN
IN DISTRESS. THAT A AND FOR RIPE
FOR THEFT IN DAMAGE- TO SMALLER
AS TO OUR TRYING IN. ON THAT
WE'RE THERE ARE NAY MARGINAL
AND- DO PROPERTY- IF FAST AND DO
. ON IT YOU SICKENING IN STATE
ARE NOT INSURED MOST OF OUR
LARGE TELL ST ARE IT STILL BEAT
THOSE LOS. SO I'M TO YOUR TO
WRAP QUESTION ABOUT THE SIZE OF
SMALL BUSINESS WE ARE TURKEY
THOSE UNDER MILLION. I IN IN
REVENUE. OKAY THAT THAT THAT'S A
NUMBER OF IT IS THERE A LAWLESS
GOING ON RIGHT NOW FOCUS KNOW
THEIR TO GO TO JAIL THE WAY THE
RICH UNDER PROP FORTY- THE MO OF
HIS. MOSTLY STORES HAVE A NON-
CAN CONFRONTATION POLICY THAT IF
SOME. STILL RESTORE THEIR- THE
ORDER EMPLOYEES NOW TO CONFIRM
THEM SO- ALLOW OF THESE FOLKS
OUT THERE. THESE BE ORGANIZE
JUST. IN JOE BLOW NO THERE NO
COST. AS A RESULT OF MORAL. SO
IT THAT. IS OUT THERE YEAH I SEE
THAT A NUMBER OF FRONTS SO. MOST
OF THE REALIZE WE HAVE THAT FACT
TOO. SO THANK YOU. INTERSTATE
THANK YOU. THE SELECTED YEAH
THANK YOU ARE I DO SHARE SOME
THE KANNST OF MY COLLEAGUES ON
MEMBER KIRK COOPER ARE TAKE. BUT
I WANT YOU KNOW AND I'M
THANKFULLY BE TALK ABOUT THIS
VERY PROBLEM. AND SO I COMMEND-
THE EFFORT HOWEVER I DO HAVE A
LITTLE BIT OF CONCERN. TO THAT
THE ISN'T IT POSSIBLE THAT
APPROPRIATING FUNDS TOWARDS A-
GOAL BUSINESS EFFORTS MAY
JEOPARDIZE. EFFORTS THAT MAY
OTHERWISE BE ABLE TO LEVERAGE-
MATCHING FUNDS LIKE FROM. THE A
NATIONALLY SIGNIFICANT FREIGHT
IN HIGHWAY PROJECT OR THE
NATIONAL INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECT
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. THAT WOULD
BE MY QUESTION. I'M NOT FAMILIAR
WITH THOSE PROGRAM SIR. MAY I
COULDN'T COMMENT ON COMPARISON.
OKAY IT SEEMS TO ME LIKE. WE
COULD THE WHAT WHAT I'M TRYING
TO SAY IS THAT IT SEEMS LIKE WE
WOULD MAXIMIZE OUR FUNDING IF WE
ARE ABLE TO- JOINT ARMS- WITH
SOME OF THESE FEDERAL PROJECTS
BETTER ADDRESSING ON THIS THAT
PROBLEM AS OPPOSED TO JUST-
HANDING IT TO YOU FOLKS TO TRY
TO TACKLE. THAT'S MY POINT. I
UNDERSTAND. THANK YOU ABSENT
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THE
QUESTIONS I HAVE A IS WHICH
BUSINESS WOULD BE ELIGIBLE VERY
SIMILAR TO MR COOPER AND TO
MISTER LACK IS CONCERNED HOW
WILL GO BIZ VERIFYING
ELIGIBILITY AND ULTIMATELY WHAT
IS THE ROLE OF INSURANCE
COMPANIES AND Y. SCOPE IS
WANTING TO INTERVENE IN THIS
PROCESS. SHARE THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE IT IS BRAND NEW.
I AM VERY COMPLEX BY NATURE. OUR
DESIRE IS TO JUST TO ENSURE THAT
AS WE STAND UP THIS PROGRAM IS
THAT WE ENSURE THAT THE STATE
DOLLARS FOR SPENT WHILE. WE ARE
WORKING WITH AN INDUSTRY EXPERTS
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT. I'M TAKE
ANALYZE SOME OF VERY THINGS THAT
YOU JUST MENTIONED AND WE ARE
HOPEFUL I'M TO HAVE THE CHECK
THE LINK WHICH APPEARS. OKAY I
THINK WHAT YOU'RE ARE JUST CHEN
KIND IN TERMS OF ESTABLISHING A
THIS PROCESS THROUGH GOBIZ AND
WHAT WILL BE. A GENERALLY YOUR
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS AND
GOALS AND MEASUREMENTS OF
SUCCESS. WHICH BUSINESSES WOULD
BEING IMPACTED VERSUS-
ESPECIALLY PRIMARILY THE ONES
THAT HAVE GOTTEN IT TO MR COOPER
POINT MR COOPER'S POINT. LARGE
ATTENTION VERSUS SOME OF THE
SMALLER MICRO BUSINESSES THAT
DON'T RECEIVE THE SAME TYPE OF
ATTENTION AND ULTIMATELY WHAT
WILL BE THE OUT REACH PROGRAM.
AND VERY SIMILAR TO THE PREVIOUS
PANEL THAT WE HAD ON SMALL
BUSINESSES WE WERE JUST
DEFINITELY VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
OUTREACH AND ENSURING THAT IT'S
NOT JUST BIG RETAILERS THAT
ULTIMATELY HAVE A SAFETY NET BUT
THERE WERE ALSO PROVIDING. SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT ARE ACTUALLY
SUFFERING ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
AS WELL NOT QUITE SURE I'VE
WE'VE HEARD- ANSWERS TO THAT.
YES MADAM CHAIR. I DO WANT TO
REITERATE. THAT OUR FOCUS ON AND
I DO BELIEVE- WE HAVE THE
EXPERTISE AND THE NETWORK TO
SUPPORT DEPLOYMENT TO SMALL
BUSINESSES- FOR LOSSES I'M FOR
COMPENSATION FOR ASSISTANCE.
THROUGH OUR NETWORK AND WE WOULD
BE MORE THAN HAPPY- TO ENGAGE
WALL IN THE PROCESS AS WE-
DEFINE I JUST PROGRAM. I WE ARE
LOOKING AT- THAT INCLUDES SOME
OF WHAT YOU HAVE MENTIONED
INSURANCE PROOF OF LOST. YOU
KNOW I'M GLAD NIGHT MEDICATION
MEASURE TO ATHLETES REPORTING I
MEAN WE ARE LOW AT OF THOSE
BEING. I'M A AND LIE WAYS ME.
THAT SMALLEST AND RETAILERS A
SAFETY. THANK YOU I'M MISS GRAY
WELL TO YOUR OSITION. AND HERE
FIRST BY HEARING- TODAY'S ALSO.
THE DEADLINE FOR TRADE BILL. AND
WE'VE HEARD IN THE MOLD FRESH
NOW THAT IS NO TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE FOR A LAW OF THESE
PROPOSAL. AND GIVEN THAT IT
TODAY IS OUR DEADLINE. WHEN DO
YOU THINK WE COULD EXPECT THAT
SO THAT THE LEGISLATURE CAN MAKE
A MORE INFORMED DECISION. I
THINK TWO WEEKS IS REALISTIC- WE
ARE ENGAGED IN RESEARCH ON THAT
BUT IF WE WERE ABLE TO- IN. THAT
OR UP THAT CAN'T. WE CERTAIN
WELL. OKAY THAT GIVES US AND-
WE'RE GONNA BE BEHIND SINCE
BUDGET TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE IS
DEADLINE FOR TODAY- IT PUTS US
IN A VERY DIFFICULT POSITION TO
BE SUPPORTIVE OF MEASURES WHEN
WE DON'T HAVE LANGUAGE. SO I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT'S ON YOUR RADAR. YES MA'AM
OKAY INTERESTING. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND AGAIN
WELCOME. WE'RE GOING TO GO ON TO
OUR OUR NEXT PANEL WHICH IS THEM
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE THE SUPPLY
CHAIN RESILIENCE WE'RE GOING TO
GO AGAIN TO MISS OUT OF SILICON
POWER MERECE. AND GOOD AFTERNOON
ONCE AGAIN MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- AGAIN OUT OF FIFTY COME
OUT I MEAN IT'S A FEW DIFFERENT
DIRECTOR HERE GO BAD. I SUPPLY
CHAIN JUST. IS A STATE WIDE AND
NATIONAL ISSUE CALIFORNIA IS
HOME TO THREE OF THE LARGEST
CARGO PORT IN THE COUNTRY. OUR
TWO LARGEST PORTS IN LA AND LONG
BEACH HANDLE 40% IMPORTANT 30%
OF THE NATION'S EXPORTS AB
RESPECTIVELY. OUR PORTS ARE
EXPERIENCINGMAJOR DISTRIBUTION
CHALLENGES SUCH AS OVERCROWDING
OF CONTAINERS AT PORT TERMINALS
SHORTAGE OF EQUIPMENT SUCH AS
CHAFF EVEN CONTAINERS AND
HISTORIC BACKLOG OF CARGO
VESSELS AT ANCHOR WAITING FOR
BIRTH SPACE. IN ADDITION TRUCK
DRIVERS HAVE BASED ON CERTAIN
KEY INCLUDING A LACK OF DETAILED
CARGO CONTAINER PICKUP
SCHEDULES. BESAL BELIEVES
CANCELLATION AND- UNCLEAR
DELIVERY DESTINATIONS. THINGS
HAPPENING WITH THAT RAILROAD
OPERATORS- THESE MAJOR SUPPLY
CHAIN PROBLEMS ARE HINDERING THE
MOVEMENT OF BUT IT'S LEADING TO
INCREASED COSTS FOR CONSUMERS
AND BUSINESSES. AND CREATING
NEGATIVE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT.
NOW FROM THE ONSET OF THE
PANDEMIC GOBIZ WORK CLOSELY WITH
OUR COLLEAGUES ACROSS STATE
GOVERNMENT TO UNDERSTAND THE
NEEDS OF. OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
ESSENTIAL WORKERS GIVING THEM
CRITICAL SUPPORT BY. MAKING SURE
THAT WE'RE GETTING P. P. E.
EQUIPMENT WITH CENTRAL WORKERS-
A LOT OF THIS WORK WITH LED BY
OUR DIRECTOR SUSTAINABLE FREIGHT
DEVELOPMENT HERE COPAYS- BUT AS
THE SUPPLY CHAIN CONCERNS
CONTINUE TO EXPAND WE LOOKED FOR
ADDITIONAL STEPS WE COULD TAKE.
AND IT WAS CRITICAL TO BRING
TOGETHER THE DIVERSE NETWORK OF
SUPPLY CAIN STAKEHOLDERS. TO
DISCUSS KEY CHALLENGES AND FIND
CREATIVE SOLUTIONS. SO THIS PAST
SEPTEMBER WE PARTNERED WITH CAL
STAR. ORDERED LONG BEACH IS CSU
LONG BEACH TO CREATE BE
CALIFORNIA'S SUPPLY CHAIN SIX
DEFINITION. SO KEY ELEMENTS OF
THAT INCLUDED A SOCIAL MEDIA
CAMPAIGN A VIRTUAL WORKSHOPS.
AND IN PERSON SUMMIT WE HAVE A
REPORT THAT WILL BE AVAILABLE
THIS MONTH- WE'RE IN THE PROCESS
OF THAT. ACTUALLY FINALIZING
THAT REPORT- THIS WEEK SO THAT
WILL BE FOR. AND I CAN BE REAL
MAKE THAT STAKEHOLDERS AGREED ON
A SET OF SHORT LONGER. STEPS
INCLUDING. CREATING TEMPORARY
STORAGE FOR. INCREASING ACCESS
TO TOP. TRANSITIONING PLAYERS IN
THE CHAIN TO TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
OPERATIONS AND REALLY COLLECTING
AND SHARING DATA. MORE
EFFICIENTLY AND EFFECTIVELY I'M
AS WELL AS INVESTING IN
INFRASTRUCTURE TO INCREASE
CAPACITY AND RESILIENCE. NOW IN
OCTOBER THE GOVERNOR ISSUED
EXECUTIVE ORDER IN NINETEEN
TWENTY ONE. WHICH DIRECTED STATE
AGENCIES TO IDENTIFY ADDITIONAL
WAYS TO ALLEVIATE CONGESTION AT
CALIFORNIA PORTS AND EXPANDED
EFFORTS TO EASE SUPPLY CHAIN
ISSUES. BY ENGAGING STAKEHOLDERS
TO DISCUSS THESE CHALLENGES. GO
BUSINESS TAX WITH ISSUE IN OUR
IN OUR- AND ALONG WITH CALL AT
TGS WE TRYING TO STATE OWNED
PROPERTY. AND PARCEL. THAT CAN
BE MADE ME LIVING TO ADDRESS
SHORT TERM CARGO CONTAINERS.
NEEDS WE'VE ALSO BEEN WORKING
WITH OUR PRIVATE PARTNERS AND T.
P. O.'S OR THIRD PARTY OPERATORS
IO ALSO CREATED AN INTERAGENCY
SUPPLY CHAIN TASK FORCE WHICH
ARE DIRECTOR GO BATES CHAIRS TO
IMPLEMENT THE GOALS AND VIDEO
AND IDENTIFY OTHERS POTENTIAL
SOLUTIONS. BRIEFLY A FEW OTHER
THINGS THAT THE STATE HAS DONE
IN THE ISSUANCE OF THE EO. BACK
IN NOVEMBER CALTRANS BEGAN
ISSUING TEMPORARY PERMITS
ALLOWING TRUCKS TO CARRY
INCREASED WEIGHT OF UP TO EIGHTY
THOUSAND POUNDS ON STATE HIGHWAY
TO HELP WITH THAT. MOVEMENT OF
GOODS WE ALSO NEARLY DOUBLED THE
DMV'S CAPACITY TO CONDUCT
COMMERCIAL DRIVING TASKS. FOR
OUR SHORTAGE OF WORKERS IN THE
INDUSTRY AND THEN ALONG WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES AT CVS. MORE RECENTLY
WE'VE BEEN WORKING. WITH THE
PORT OF OAKLAND AS WELL AS THE
STAR EXPORTERS IN FINDING SPACE
AND EVEN REALLY HAVING A HARD
TIME GETTING A PRODUCT. OUT AND
SENT BACK TO EVERYWHERE. ALL
OVER THE WORLD- ONLY GROWERS AND
- HAVE REALLY- STE AND WE CAN
WORK THAT TO. REALLY KIND HELPED
HIM- EASE SOME OF THIS MOVIE-
BUT WE KNOW MORE TO BE DONE. AND
THE SUPPLY CHAIN REQUIRES TERM A
INVESTING TO TRUE ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE. SO TO THAT END GO VISITS
. THIRTY MIN DOLLAR. FOR OPERATE
AND PROCESS IMPROVEMENTS THE
PORTS. TO ENABLE EFFICIENT CARGO
MOVEMENT REDUCE CONGESTION AND
CREATE OPPORTUNITIES TO INCREASE
CARGO VOLUME BY PROMOTING AND
BUILDING MUSICIANS HE'S- NOW WE
KNOW THAT THE SUPPLY CHAIN
ISSUES ARE A COMPLETE THE
COMPLEX SYSTEM OF SYSTEMS. AND
THERE'S A LACK OF CENTRALIZED
DATA THAT IT CONTRIBUTES TO MUCH
OF THE CONFUSION THAT I OUTLINED
EARLIER- AS MUCH OF THIS
OPERATION. AND SUPPORT THAT-
THAT SPENDING BE CONTRIBUTED
TOWARDS INCLUDING DATA SHARING
ACCESS AND MODERNIZATION IN
ORDER TO ENABLE REAL TIME
SITUATIONAL UPDATES. INCREASED
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN CARRIERS.
OPTIMIZE SHIPMENT ROUTE AND
ELIMINATE BLIND HAND. SO THE
DATED MAY MORE CUTS AND IS
MODERNIZE THE WITH THAT MANAGED
AND MEMBERS HAPPY TO ANSWERING
QUESTION. THANK YOU MISS CUMPLIR
ROMERO LET'S HEAR FROM THE L. A.
O. OFFICE BY THE DEPARTMENT OF.
THE WE GO TO THE DICE. RIGHT YES
BRING WITH OF THE LEGISLATIVE
AND OFFICE. AND THAT'S THE
PRAYER I THIS PER IS PART OF A-
PACK THIS. PACKAGE. AND IT
TURNED OUT THAT THE D. THE PER
IS ON BEING TO. SO UNABLE TO
EVALUATE THE MERITS PROPOSED
WITHOUT INFORMATION ABOUT HOW
THE PHONE WOULD BE ON THE YOU SO
. ARE FOLLOWING TO SEE THE
INDUSTRY TIMES YOU HE'S FUNDS TO
IMPLEMENT DIRECTLY. PUT FORTH
COMING FROM THE FEDERAL HURT
COMMISSION PERTAINING TO THE- OF
COMMON DATA STANDARDS. AMONG THE
- THE CARRIER AND SHIPPERS
SHIPPERS. AND RAIL AND SO FORTH
SO IMPROVE DID IN. HE CERTAINLY
COULD OVER. ADDRESS SOME OF THE
SUPPLIES PROBLEMS WE WOULD
OBSERVE THERE'S NOT OBVIOUS ROLE
FOR THE STATE IN THIS BECAUSE
THE PRIMARY BENEFICIARIES A
PRIVATE COMPANIES WITH CLEAR
PRESS. TRUST IN ADOPTING IT IS
STANDARDS AND- AND SO IT- WE
KNOW THAT OTHER CITY. ALSO. IT
EXPERTISE AND TECHNICAL GOODS
MOVEMENT ISSUES. MISTER
WEATHERFORD CAN YOU- YOU CAUGHT
MY ATTENTION WITH THE
BENEFICIARY BEING A PUBLIC
COMPANY A PUBLIC COMPANY CAN YOU
ELABORATE ON THAT A BIT. WELL
ALL THE THAT THE PRIMARY
BENEFICIARIES OF IMPROVING THE
DIDN'T DROP. REALLY ARE. PUSHING
CARRIERS WHICH- HERE OFTEN-
EVERY TERMINAL OPERATORS WHICH
ON THE SPACE FROM THE PORTS AND
THE TRUCKERS AND THE RAILROAD
IT'S A WHOLE. ABOUT IT DID YOU
LEAVE ME. YES I'M SORRY CAN YOU
CAN YOU BEGIN AGAIN YOU KIND OF
YOU BURKE. DIGITIZED A BIT. GOOD
QUITE THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION TO
LET ME MAKE MY BROKEN BODY AND
WITH THE LOW LET ME STOP MY
VIDEO. PERFECT FOR IF YOU CAN BE
FOUND WE WERE MAKING IS THAT-
THE BENEFICIARIES OF THE DATA IT
BEEN PROVING DATA. AVAILABILITY
IS- IT'S PRIVATE OCEAN SHIPPERS
RAILROADS TRUCKERS AND- SO FORTH
AND SO WE'RE NOT CLEAR THERE'S A
PUBLIC ROLE IN SUPPORTING THIS
AND IF THERE IS A PUBLIC ROAD
MIGHT BE MORE PERFECT IF
FEDERAL. OF ROLE AS OPPOSED TO A
STABLE. THANK YOU FOR THAT KIND
. MUCH APPRECIATED OUR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. YOU
TOMORROW JOHNSON DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NOTHING TO ADD AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU I'M GONNA ASK
FOR THE MEMBERS OF THE DIS IF
THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS. WELL I
HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS A
SAME AS PREVIOUS- ISSUES WHEN
WITH THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
BE AVAILABLE FOR THIS PROPOSAL.
I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- WE ARE
I'M IN THE PROCESS OF DEVELOPING
THAT AS WELL AND HOPING TO.
COORDINATE WITH YOUR STAFF AND
PROVIDE YOU WITH AN UPDATE- I'LL
DEFER TO MY COLLEAGUE THAT
FINANCE IF WE HAVE A- MORE
SPECIFIC TIME FRAME. TOMORROW
JOHNSON THE PARDON OF FINANCE-
WE ARE WORKING TO THE LANGUAGE
AND- INTEND TO HAVE OF THE
LANGUAGE TO USE IN. THANK YOU
AND I- MISS JOHNSON I HATE TO
PUT YOU ON THE SPOT AGAIN BUT
WHAT THE SOON MEAN WOULDN'T WHEN
IS THAT A DATE FOR THAT EXACTLY
SINCE DEADLINE WAS TODAY. YES
MADAM CHAIR- WE ARE WORKING TO
LANGUAGE AND WE INTEND TO- IT IS
OUR GOAL TO HAVE THE LANGUAGE-
POSTED BY THE END OF THIS WEEK.
OKAY I ASK AGAIN BECAUSE YOU
KNOW WE ARE THINKING ABOUT WHAT
IS THE STATE ROLE IN
COORDINATING AND HOW WHAT IS THE
BALANCE OF HOW WE'RE SUPPOSED TO
DO THIS WORK WITHOUT ANY TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE. AND THE
LEGISLATURE MAKING A DECISION ON
THE PROPOSAL. IS VERY VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WE GET THAT- AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE TO THE QUESTION
TO THE COMMENTS MADE BY MR
WHETHER FOR WHAT IS THIS ROLE IN
. IN AND HOW IS IT THAT BALANCE
WITH THE FEDERAL ROLE AT AT THE
PORTS. YEAH I THINK YOU
MENTIONED THAT IS AN EXCELLENT
POINT- MADE BY MISTER
WEATHERFORD I THINK WHAT I WILL
ADD IS THAT. THIS IS A AGAIN AS
I MENTIONED A VERY COMPLEX-
SYSTEM WHERE THERE REALLY IS NO
ONE ENTITY THAT'S TASKED WITH
OVERSEEING. THE VARIOUS MOVING
PARTS. WE ARE WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH OUR COUNTERPARTS AT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- FNC IN
PARTICULAR THAT MARITIME
COMMISSION AND- IS ALSO LOOKING
AT THIS VERY VERY CLOSELY- IT
REALLY IS TAKING. EVERYONE I
THINK TO WORK COLLABORATIVELY TO
COME UP WITH THE- MY SOLUTION
AND- YOU KNOW MOVE THIS FORWARD
BUT WORK BUT I CAN'T SAY IS AS
FAR AS- THE STATE. INVOLVEMENT
IS THAT- AS I MENTIONED IN MY
COMMENTS EARLIER- YOU KNOW WHAT
HAVING ISSUES WITH YOU KNOW
GETTING P. P. E. EQUIPMENT TO-
YOU KNOW ESSENTIAL WORKERS OR
TWERK FRONTLINE WORKERS BECAUSE-
ITEMS WERE JUST TAKING. YOU KNOW
MONTHS TO ARRIVE YOU KNOW PROPER
MATH. BETTER EQUIPMENT- I THINK
THAT THAT DOES BECOME YOU KNOW A
STATE ISSUE THAT THAT THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY YOU KNOW OF OUR OF
OUR- OF OUR FRONTLINE WORKERS- I
ACT FOR INSTANCE I MENTIONED.
EARLIER WE JUST WERE OVERWHELMED
WITH HEARING FROM OUR
AGRICULTURAL EXPORTERS. WHO JUST
WERE NOT HAVING ANY LUCK BEING
ABLE TO SEND. THEIR PRODUCTS-
ABROAD OR TO WHOEVER THEY YOU
KNOW THEY'RE THERE THEIR CLIENT
IS- AND THAT DOES AFFECT US AS
WELL BECAUSE IS YOU KNOW I'M
THOSE PRODUCTS ESPECIALLY. OUT
PRODUCTS HAVE A VERY SHORT SHELF
LIFE. AND SO IF THOSE ARE ARE
OUT AND SITTING. FOR A LONG
PERIOD OF TIME THAT
UNFORTUNATELY IS REALLY GOING TO
IMPACT OUR OUR AG INDUSTRY- OUR
GROWERS AND REALLY HAVE A
TRICKLE DOWN EFFECT. AND SO-
LITTLE BIT IS REALLY DONE-
REALLY SINCE. THE ONSET OF- GO
VISIT SECTION TO OUR OUR
FREIGHT- POSITION. ANYMORE
RECENTLY TO WITH A- ORDER AND
SUCH. IS BECAUSE- A. COME V. OF
SORTS YOU KNOW WE'VE WORKED WITH
ALL STATE. FOR ACROSS THE FIGHT
. SPECTRUM IS AGAIN VERY LONG
AND COME. TO REALLY YOU KNOW
FOLKS TO THE TABLE AND FIGURE
OUT. WHAT WHAT WHAT WHAT WERE
THAT ROOM IS FOR THE STATE TO
YOU- TO WORK AND IN THIS CASE WE
FEEL THAT. THAT THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS- WHILE WE'RE STILL
DEVELOPING BEAT BEAT PROPOSAL
AND SPECIFICALLY ON THE DATA
SIDE. BILL THAT THERE DEFINITELY
IS SOME ROOM THERE FOR US TO
PROVIDE AN INCENTIVE. TO HELP-
REALLY COORDINATE THIS THAT'S
PROPOSAL. I THANK YOU FOR THAT
THERE'S CURRENTLY A FREIGHT
POSITION WITHIN GO BIZ THAT HAS
BEEN VACANT HOW SOON WILL YOU BE
HIRING A PERSON TO OVERSEE THAT
. YEAH THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SO
THAT POSITION JUST BY THE
GENTLEMEN- WHO HAD IT JUST
RETIRED- AT THE END OF THIS LAST
YEAR. AND SO WE HAVE- POSTED THE
POSITION AND WE ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF- FINDING A CANDIDATE
SO WE EXPECT TO HAVE HOPE WE
HAVE THAT BILL WITHIN THE NEXT
THIRTY DAYS OR SO. THAT'S GOOD
TO KNOW. DOES THE
ADMINISTRATION'S THIRTY MILLION
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND PROPOSAL
FOR OPERATIONAL AND PROCESS
IMPROVEMENTS AT THE PORT
INCLUDE. B. TWENTY MILLION
REQUESTS FROM THE PORT OF LOS
ANGELES- FOR AN END TO END
DIGITAL SOLUTION THAT SUPPORTS
INTER OPERABILITY AND INTEGRATED
DATA DATA SHARING ACROSS THE
SUPPLY CHAIN. IF NOT AT ALL WHAT
PORTIONS OF ANY ARE INCLUDED.
YES THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THAT'S
A GOOD QUESTION AND AGAIN GOING
BACK TO SOME OF MY EARLIER
COMMENT- WHAT WITH MADE IT
CHALLENGING IS THAT REALLY MOST.
OF US. STAKEHOLDERS NOT JUST
SUPPORT THEMSELVES BUT OTHER
SHIPPING LINES- YOU KNOW THE
ENTIRE SPECTRUM- THEY EVERYONE
HAVE THEIR OWN SYSTEM IN PLACE.
THE PUBLIC IN PARTICULAR HAVE-
MADE SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS
OVER THE YEARS INTO THEIR OWN
SYSTEMS. AND THE CHALLENGES THAT
BECAUSE THERE'S REALLY NO
COMPATIBILITY THERE'S NO NO
FLUIDITY- PER SE FOR- FOR THIS
PROCESS- THAT'S REALLY MADE A
VERY CHALLENGING AND SO. IF YOU
ASK ME ONE PORTMAN OTHER EACH
ONE. YOU KNOW HAVE THEIR OWN
IDEA OF MAYBE WHAT MAKES SENSE-
HOWEVER WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO
TAKE A STEP BACK AND SEE IF
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO ALIGN.
THE SYSTEMS- AND MOVED OUT SO
NO. TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION I
DON'T CARE THAT TWENTY MILLION
AND IS NOT PART OF THIS
PROPOSAL- AGAIN WE'RE TRYING TO
FOCUS ON A BROADER APPROACH.
THAT INCORPORATES ALL
STAKEHOLDERS. UNDER ABROAD
APPROACH TO. ALL STATE. WELL ALL
STAKEHOLDERS USE DIFFERENT
TECHNOLOGY SEEMS COMPLICATED.
YEAH MMHM OKAY- ALGO BIZ ALSO
PLAYS A ROLE IN THE STATE'S
TRANSITION TO A CARBON NEUTRAL
ECONOMY ESPECIALLY AS THESE
ACTIVITIES RELATE TO THE STATE'S
LOGISTICAL NETWORK DOES GO BIZ
BELIEVE THAT IT HAS SUFFICIENT
RESOURCES TO SUCCESSFULLY PLAY
THIS ROLE. YES THAT'S A GOOD
QUESTION- SO WE ARE GETTING TWO
PRONG- ANSWER HERE SO WE ARE
WORKING CLOSELY- OF COURSE WITH
OUR COLLEAGUES AT CAL STYLE. AND
IN THEIR EFFORTS ON THEIR
FREIGHT MOBILITY PLAN THIS
COMPILED THE COMPLETE YOU JUST
RAISED AS PART OF THEIR THEIR
MOBILITY PLAN AS WELL AND SO
THERE IS AN ASPECT THERE AND
THEN ON OUR END- WE DO HAVE. A
TEAM- THAT HANDLES A LOT OF OUR-
ZERO MISSION HOURS I'VE TEAM- ON
STAFF IS ALSO VERY SUPPORTIVE-
TO HELPING US ACCOMPLISH AS WELL
SO WE DO FEEL THAT WE HAVE THE
RESOURCES BOTH IN HOUSE AND THEN
ALSO THROUGH OUR COLLABORATIVE
EFFORTS WITH OUR OUR COLLEAGUES
. THANK YOU FOR THAT IF THERE
ARE NO ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS WE
CAN MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT. WERE ON
. BETTER HEARING MY NAME YES
TOMORROW JOHNSON DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I WOULD JUST LIKE TO-
CLARIFY ON ON THE LANGUAGE
PIECE- WE- DID NOT PROPOSE A
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE BUT WE DO
HAVE A BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE WE
BELIEVE THAT THAT WAS THAT THAT
IS SUFFICIENT TO- UP FOR THE
OPERATIONS OF THE EVENT FUNDING
. OKAY THANK YOU WILL LOOK INTO
THAT AS WELL THANK YOU MISS
JOHNSON. WE ARE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO ISSUED NUMBER SIX INCLUSIVE
INNOVATION HUB PROGRAM
EXPANSIONS MISS GRAY. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR TURTLING BREAK
DIRECTOR CALLOW IS BA- IT
REGARDING OUR INCLUSIVE
INNOVATION HUBS- WE ARE
REQUESTING AN ADDITIONAL TWENTY
MILLION TO ACCOMPLISH- A FEW
SPECIFIC THINGS ON IT WITH THE
EXPANSION OF THIS PROGRAM FIRST
DISPLAY ADS TO MEET ADDITIONAL
AYE HUBS- TO THE TEN THAT WERE
PRINTED IN THE PREVIOUS YEAR. ON
AND IF WE DESIRE TO DO SO- AS WE
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE ONE I HAD HER
. SURGERY REGION. ADDITIONALLY
WE WOULD LIKE TO ADD TO FUNDING
FOR THE PROGRAM. THROUGH- HE
ENTIRELY OF THE PARTY FOR YEARS
AND FOUR YEARS I THE AND- WOULD
LIKE TO. THE ENTREPRENEURSHIP
FIND WHICH IS DESIGNED ARE
DESIGNED TO ACCELERATE THE
GROWTH OF SMALL BUSINESS
PARTICIPANTS IN EACH OF THE
REGIONAL AYE INCLUSIVE
INNOVATION HOPS. I STATUS ON THE
EXISTING PROGRAM. WHICH IS
DESIGNED TO STIMULATE
PARTNERSHIPS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND JOB CREATION FOR
UNDERSERVED GEOGRAPHIC AREAS
INDUSTRY SECTORS AND BUSINESS
OWNERS- WE HAVE BEEN THROUGH THE
RFP SUBMISSION PROCESS FOR THAT
FIRST ROUND TEN IT OPENED UP TO
ELEVENTH I'M CLOSE DECEMBER
SIXTEENTH. WE'VE RECEIVED TWENTY
TWO APPLICATIONS AND ARE
CURRENTLY GOING THROUGH THE
COURT PROCESS. WE'LL TAKE
QUESTIONS AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU LET'S HEAR FROM THE L. EIGHT
OH PLEASE MISTER WHETHER FORD
FOLLOWED BY- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. MY BRAIN WHETHER FOR
WITH LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AND- WHAT ARE COMING FROM
THIS IT'S A BIT DIFFICULT TO
EVALUATE YOU KNOW THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSING HAVE
MORE MONEY TO THE INCLUSIVE
INNOVATION HUB PROGRAM. AND-
THERE WAS PRETTY. PROGRAM BUT TO
OUR KNOWLEDGE IT'S NEVER BEEN
FULLY ON THE REALLY GOING TO
TELL YOU WAITED SO WE DON'T
KNOW. YOU KNOW WHERE THE OTHER-
SOURCE THE FUNDING WERE COMING
FROM YOU KNOW THE INITIAL THE
PREVIOUS INNOVATION PROGRAM
DIDN'T HAVE A LOT OF STATE
FUNDS. SO- YOU KNOW WE DON'T
KNOW A LOT ABOUT- THE ACTIVITIES
I CAN IN A IN A WAY THAT WE CAN
EAT ANALYZE AND EVALUATE AND SO.
SECURITY ADMINISTRATION'S ASKING
FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDS TO EXPAND
EXTEND THE PROGRAM AND- IT'S
JUST HARD TO EVALUATE IT SO-
WEEK. YOUR RECORD WE ARE
SUGGESTING THAT PERHAPS- ADDING
SOME LANGUAGE ON TO THIS
PROPOSALS AND YOU KNOW COULD BE
DONE BY THE BILL- TO- TO REQUIRE
THEM TO COLLECT. POINTS METRICS
ON ABOUT THE AN INNOVATION HUB
SO THAT WE CAN- I IN THE FUTURE
HAVE SOME- EVIDENCE TO YOU KNOW
INFORM ANY ADDITIONAL PROPOSED
CHANGES TO THE PROGRAM. THANK
YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NINE
JOHNSON DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
NOTHING TO AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU. THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HAVE
QUESTIONS MISTER LUCKY YEAH I
JUST HAVE A SPECIFIC QUESTION AS
IT RELATES TO THE-
ENTREPRENEURSHIP FUND. HOW WILL
THE FIRE SMALL BUSINESSES BE
CHOSEN. AN EXCELLENT QUESTION
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LACKEY ON THAT WE
ARE PROPOSED TO CREATED AN
ADVISORY COUNCIL AND TO LIFT AS
SIGN A STAFF PERSON. I'M REALLY
TO BE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
PROGRAM I'M WE KNOW FROM THE
HISTORY OF THE PROGRAM THAT THE-
THE- INTEREST IN THE PROGRAM. IT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN BECAUSE IT DID
NOT COME WITH FUNDING. AND WE
BELIEVE THAT WE CAN SHORE UP AND
CALIFORNIA'S COMPETITIVE THE
ADS. WE DO INNOVATION AND
TECHNOLOGY VERY WELL AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THE INVESTMENT
INVEST WILL HELP TO YOU I SEED
AND ACCELERATE THE GROWTH OF THE
SMALL BUSINESSES THAT
PARTICIPATED IN THE PROGRAM. AND
SELL ASSETS WE WILL STAND UP IN
ADVISORY COUNCIL THAT WILL
CONSIST OF REPRESENTATION FROM
THE HUBS FROM THE REGIONS IN
WHICH THE HUBS RESIDE. ON THE
AND- STAFF INDUSTRY EXPERTS AND
THEY WILL WEIGH IN ON THE
APPLICATION PROCESS ADDITIONAL.
ONLY THOSE BUSINESSES THAT HAVE
BEEN IMPLICATED OR ACCELERATED
AND HAVE AN EXISTING
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE HELP
THROUGH WHICH THEY APPLY WILL
BE. ALLOWED TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE FUNDING PROCESS I'LL LASTLY
EACH OF THE HUBS WILL. HAVE
FIVE. AND BUSINESSES THAT THEY
ARE ALLOWED TO CELEBRATE EACH
YEAR I'M. AT A AT A MAXIMUM. I
THANK YOU I LAST YEAR CAN
CHANGES WERE ENACTED FOR BOTH I
HOPE TO ANSWER THIS PROPOSAL
SEEMS TO MAKE ADDITIONAL CHANGES
TO BOTH PROGRAMS WHY IS CARILLO
IS BA PROPOSING ADDITIONAL
CHANGES WITHOUT ANALYZING THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF EITHER PROGRAM. IT IS NOT MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT THE LANGUAGE THAT WE WROTE
IS MAKING CHANGES TO BOTH
PROGRAMS. WE ARE ONLY SUGGESTING
EIGHT CHANGE- IN OUR PROGRAM THE
INCLUSIVE INNOVATION HUB
PROGRAM- WE ARE LOOKING TO YOU I
ATTY. ALIGN WITH AND LEVERAGE
THE INVESTMENT OF THE COMMUNITY
ECONOMIC RESILIENCE FINES AND WE
BELIEVE THAT WE CAN SERVE THE
GEOGRAPHIES AT THE STATE BETTER
IF WE ALIGN WITH THE REGIONAL
MAP THAT- THAT THEIR OVERSIGHT
BODY HAS CREATED. I AM IN AND WE
FEEL THAT IT'S NECESSARY TO DO
SO TO GIVE. ESPECIALLY THOSE
REGIONS WITHOUT RELYING
GEOGRAPHIES I'M THE SAME
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THE REDUCE
RESOURCES AS THOSE IN. MORE.
DENSELY POPULATED AREAS. OKAY
THE- THE PC PS FOUR FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND FOR AN ADDITIONAL FOUR
ADMINISTRATIVE COST IS THIS IN
ADDITION TO ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS
ON TOP OF THE CURRENT I HOPE TO
PROGRAM AND THE SURF PROGRAM AND
WHAT IS THE TOTAL FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS THAT WILL
GO INTO THE THREE PROGRAMS.
MADAM CHAIR I'M NOT. AWARE AS IT
MINISTRY TO COST AND FORMER
CANCER PROGRAM AGAIN WE HAVE THE
ONLY PUT FORTH I'M COSTS RELATED
TO OUR PROGRAM. AND TWO I ASM
LACKEY'S SWEETS I THINK WE WANT
TO- BE SURE THAT WE HAS THE
OVERSIGHT AND MONITORING AND
EVALUATION NECESSARY TO RUN IT
THE- INNOVATION AND
ENTREPRENEURSHIP PROGRAM. AT
THIS PROPOSAL CONSISTS OF AND WE
CANNOT DO SO WITHOUT ADDITIONAL
SOURCES SO WE CAN'T DO THE BEST
JOB. AND. WITHOUT ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES. I'M MISS GREAT WHAT
ARE THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS FOR THE I HOPE TO PROGRAM
. HELLO WE DON'T CURRENTLY HAVE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS. AND IN IN
THE EXISTING AND BUDGET THAT WAS
IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR THAT HOW
WILL- ALWAYS BE A OVERSEE THAT I
HAVE PROGRAM TO ENSURE
HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED
BUSINESSES BE REACHED VERY
SIMILAR TO QUESTIONS THAT WE
HAVE HAD IN OTHER PANELS AT WHAT
METRICS AND MEANT AND BENCHMARKS
WILL BE USED TO TRACK SUCCESS.
EXCELLENT AND AGAIN TRYING TO-
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY WE WANT
THE ADMINISTRATIVE FINES IS SO
THAT WE CAN DO THAT EXACT KIND
OF THE IN DEPTH ANALYSIS DATA
TRACKING. MONITORING AND
EVALUATION OF THE PROGRAMS ABOUT
WE DON'T. FEEL THAT WE CAN
ENSURE THAT WE ARE HITTING THE
GEOGRAPHIES AND THE UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES THAT WE YOUR DESIRE
TO DO SO WITH THE PROGRAM UNLESS
WE HAVE THE RESOURCES. TO DO
THAT WE ARE KEEPING I'M TRYING
READY TO UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
AND IT IS MEANT TO NOT ONLY
REACH THOSE COMMUNITIES BUT TO
REACH UNDER REPRESENTED AND
UNDERSERVED. COUNTERS AS WELL.
AND AS A FALL UP THE INITIAL AYE
HERB PROGRAM FOCUSED ON INDUSTRY
SECTORS AND WAS INTENDED TO
BALANCE THE STATE'S EXISTING
REGIONAL ECONOMIC. DEVELOPMENT
FOCUS NOW THAT I HOMES HAVE NO
SPECIFIC INDUSTRY FOCUS HOW WILL
REGIONAL I HOPE DEMONSTRATE IT
IS CAPABLE OF SUPPORTING
ENTREPRENEURS IN EVERY
INNOVATION TECH SECTOR. IF THEY
ARE ALIGNING WITH OTHER PROGRAMS
WHAT MAKES HIM A UNIQUE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROVIDER.
AND I'M NOT SURE THAT I
UNDERSTAND IT THE WE ARE
ALIGNING WITH OTHER PROGRAMS WE
ALIGNED WITH THE OTHER PROGRAMS
IN ORDER TO LEVERAGE THIS STATE
INVESTMENT ACT. I'M I'M I'M NOT
SURE I'M GETTING THE- FULL
CONTEXT OF THAT QUESTION. WELL
IF YOU'RE IT'S IF YOU ARE
COMBINING EFFORTS WITH OTHER
PROGRAMS WHAT MAKES THE I HOPE
PROGRAM UNIQUE. I'M SO I THINK
THAT IT WOULD BE WRONG TO THAT
WE ARE THIS WITH ANOTHER WE ARE
NOT WE ARE SIMPLY TO ALIGN OUR
R. SO THE IT WE CAN TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE OTHER
INVESTMENT AND WE'VE HOPE THAT
ONCE- THE- ARE BETTER SERVED
THROUGH THE SIR PROGRAM WOULD
ALSO WANT TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF-
THAT KNOWLEDGE BASE THAT WERE.
THE WORK THAT DOING IN THIS
COMMUNITIES OUT WE THINK THAT IT
JUST OFFERS OUR CONSTITUENCY
ACROSS THE STATE A MORE ROBUST
AND PROGRAM. WE DON'T WANT TO I
WAS TRYING TO SAY WE DON'T WANT
TO OPERATE IN A VACUUM I'M STILL
THE THAT WOULD BE MY INITIAL
RESPONSE TO THAT REGARDING THE
INDUSTRY CLUSTERS WE ARE LOOKING
TO HAVE THE INDUSTRY
SPECIALIZATION IN TERMS OF
TECHNOLOGY INNOVATION CLEAN TACK
ON TECHNOLOGY TRANSFER SMALL
BUSINESS INNOVATION RESEARCH WE
ARE LOOKING TO CAPITALIZE AGAIN
ON AS THEY SAID EARLIER ON
CALIFORNIA'S. EDGE WE HAVE MORE
I IN THE STATE WE ATTRACT MORE
CAPITAL AND THE STATE THEN ALL
OF THE OTHER STATES IN THE UNION
. AND WE TO PUT THAT EXPERTISE
TO WORK AND WE NEED TO DRAW ON
TALENT FROM OTHER REGIONS TO
SHORE UP WE'RE WE KNOW THAT WE
HAVE DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
AND WIDELY DISINVEST IT
COMMUNITIES TO GIVE EVERYONE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS PART OF OUR ECONOMY WE NEED
AN ECONOMY THAT WORKS FOR US
ALL. NOT AS THANKS SELECT FEW.
THANK YOU FOR THAT MS GRAY
APPRECIATE IT APPRECIATE THE
RESPONSES WE ARE WRAPPING UP
VERY SOON WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO WHERE IF THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO. A ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO STAY IN A
BILL AT THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IS
STAYING ABILITY FUND. THANK YOU
AGAIN WE HAVE MISS- I'M SORRY MR
CHYNA PEREIRA ON THE LINE. CAN
YOU MISTER- GOOD AFTERNOON CHECK
REAL MEMBERS MY NAME IS KIND OF
PRAYER SENIOR ADVISER FOR
BUSINESS DEVELOPMENTOVER
GULBIS- WE ARE REQUESTING FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION AND ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND DOLLARS
STARTING IN FISCAL YEARS TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR TO PROVIDE
SHORT TERM GRANTS TO LOCAL
ENTITIES FACING SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES TO THEIR NEAR TERM
BUDGET SUSTAINABILITY BUT ALSO
DEMONSTRATING A CLEAR COMMITMENT
TO ADVANCING MORE CLIMATE
RESILIENT AND DIVERSIFIED
ECONOMIC FUTURE. THESE GRANTS
WILL INJECT FUNDS IN THE COUNTY
LET PROJECTS THAT ARE AIMED AT
PROCESS IMPROVEMENT ECONOMIC
DIVERSIFICATION CLIMATE
TECHNOLOGIES ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND JOB CREATION. AS
THESE ECONOMIES GRAPPLE WITH THE
IMPACT OF COVER NINETEEN AND
CLIMATE CHANGE THESE GRANTS WILL
OFFER FLEXIBILITY TO THE
QUALIFIED COUNTIES ENABLING
INVESTMENT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
FUTURE ECONOMIC RESILIENCE
WITHOUT THE NEED TO REDUCE
UNNECESSARY ALLOCATIONS. TO
VITAL SERVICES FOR THE COMMUNITY
. FIVE THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
. THANK YOU FOR THAT MISTER PART
OF BETA LET'S GO TO THE L. A. O.
FOLLOWED BY THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE MISTER WEATHERFORD. IT
SEEMS MISTER WEATHERFORD MAY
HAVE SOME TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES
RIGHT NOW SO LET'S GO TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MS JOHNSON
. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR NOTHING
TO ADD AT THIS TIME. BEFORE WE
GET- DELHI OFFICE BACK ON THE
LINE A MINUTE TURN IT OVER TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY- MISTER PER- BUT A LOT CAN
GO THIS PROVIDE EXAMPLES OF WHAT
PROJECTS THEY BELIEVE WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THIS FUNDING. YES
THERE ARE CERTAIN TYPES OF
PRODUCTS WITH COULD BE ELIGIBLE
FOR THIS FUNDING IN SOME SENSE
THEY COULD BE- PROJECTS RELATED
TO INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS
FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE WORK
FORCE TRAINING. OR OTHER
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT PRIORITIES
IT COULD BE USED FOR GRANTS
SOLICITATION OR USE OF MATT AS
MATCH FUNDS FOR FEDERAL GRANT
OPPORTUNITIES WHERE THEY'RE
LOCAL OR THEIR REVENUES DO NOT
ALLOW FOR THEM TO ACTUALLY GO
AND OBTAIN THOSE FEDERAL GRANTS.
AS WELL AS SUPPLEMENTING
ADDITIONAL PROGRAMS THAT MAY
HAVE GAPS IN THEIR ADDITIONAL
FUNDING SO FOR INSTANCE-
SOMETHING THAT CONVENTION AND A
COUPLE TIMES DURING THE HEARING
IS THE SURF PROGRAM. THERE ARE
CURRENTLY NO ALLOCATION OF SIX
HUNDRED MILLION WHICH WOULD CAP
THE NUMBER OF DOLLARS A TRIBUTE
TO A SPECIFIC PROJECT. AT
ROUGHLY FORTY SIX MILLION
POTENTIALLY. IN WHICH CASE THE
PROJECT THAT GOES OVER THAT
AMOUNT AND IS QUALIFIED BY BOTH
THAT COMMITTEE AS WELL AS THIS
PROGRAM. COULD OBTAIN THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDS NECESSARY TO
BRIDGE THAT THAT SHORTFALL. AND
OUR THEIR X. STAY PROGRAM THAT
WOULD POSSIBLY FUND THESE
PROJECTS. THERE ARE EXISTING
PROGRAMS WHICH COULD FUND PARTS
OR HOLES OF THESE PROJECTS BUT
MAY NOT BE ABLE TO SUPPLEMENT
THE ENTIRE SCOPE OF THE ENTIRE
PROJECT OR MAY NOT BE WITHIN.
THE DESIGNATED LANES OF FUNDING
BASED ON THE GUARD RAILS BUILT
BY THOSE PROGRAMS ITSELF. IT
SEEMED TO BE A LITTLE BIT MORE
FLEXIBLE THAN SOME OF THOSE
WHICH HAVE ALREADY BEEN
ESTABLISHED ON THE PREVIOUS
YEAR'S BUDGET. I THINK SOUNDS
THE- SOUNDS LIKE THERE ARE
OPPORTUNITIES WITH EXISTING
PROGRAMS AND PERHAPS NOT IN
ALIGNMENT IN TERMS OF. WHAT THAT
CAN POTENTIALLY LOOK LIKE. OKAY
THAT WOULD BE. OKAY THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS AND WE ARE
UNABLE TO GET- MISTER WHETHER
FOR BACK ON WE CAN MOVE ONTO THE
NEXT AND FINAL LOOKS LIKE ALMOST
NO NOT YET ALMOST A ISSUE NUMBER
EIGHT TECHNICAL ASSISTANT
EXPANSION PROGRAM AND CAPITAL
INFUSION PROGRAMME SPACE GRAY.
THANK YOU AGAIN. YOU CAN CHAIR-
SIEGERT ASSISTANCE EXTENT
EXPANSION PROGRAM ON TAPE FUNDS
A NETWORK OF THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROVIDERS ACROSS THE
STATE I'M THROUGH OUR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE EXPANSION PROGRAMMING
CAPITAL INFUSION PROGRAMME ALL
RIGHT MANY OF OUR GRANTEES ARE
SB DC'S WAS SPECIALIZED
PROGRAMMING TO SUPPORT
UNDERSERVED SMALL BUSINESSES AND
WE ON THE IN THE CURRENT YEAR
GRANTED RIGHT AT SEVENTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS ACROSS EIGHTY
NINE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
CENTERS THE UNDER FORTY FOR
UNIQUE APPLICATIONS- AND- THE
AVERAGE. OF THE DEMANDING AWARDS
FOR THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS OF
THE PROGRAM I BELIEVE HAVE BEEN
INCLUDED IN YOUR PACKETS WE'RE
REQUESTING TWO THINGS ON AN
ADDITIONAL SIX MILLION FOR THE
UPCOMING- FISCAL YEAR BUDGET AND
TWENTY SIX MILLION ON GOING ON
THIRTEEN WHICH INCLUDES THREE
MILLION FOR THE CAPITAL.
INFUSION PROGRAMME. THANK YOU DO
WE HAVE MISTER WHETHER FORD BACK
ON THE LINE FOR THE L. A. O. AT
THIS TIME. NOT YET OKAY MISTER
JOHNSON A PERMANENT FINANCE.
THANK YOU NOTHING TO ADD AT THIS
TIME OKAY THANK YOU AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. ALL RIGHT- CAN
GO THIS EXPLAIN HOW THEY
PROJECTED AN INCREASE OF SIX
MILLION. YES MA'AM. WE ENDED I'M
A LOOK BACK- OVER AT THE FIRST
FOUR YEARS OF THE PROGRAM I AND
WE CALCULATED AGAIN AT THE STATE
DOLLARS HE DIDN'T ON THE NUMBER
OF CENTERS THANK DANTE AND BE
OVER SUBSCRIPTION AND EVERYTHING
AT THE PROGRAM AND WHAT I NEED
AND FIGHT OVER SUBSCRIPTION IS
ON THE- AMOUNT OF DOLLARS THAT
WE REQUESTED GREATER THAN THE
BUDGET THAT WE HAD AVAILABLE AND
WE TOOK AN AVERAGE OF THAT
NUMBER AND. THAT IS HOW WE
LANDED. ON THAT NOTE WE ARE.
THANK YOU AT THE TAPE AND THE
PROGRAMS ARE PROPOSED TO BE
ONGOING- FUNDING WHAT REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS ARE INCLUDED FOR
THESE PROGRAMS. YES OUR I'M
CENTERS CURRENTLY RIGHT NOW
PROVIDE WE GET ORDERED LEGAL
FORTY. ON THE FOR BOTH OF THE
PROGRAMS- AND WE HAVE SURPRISED
. OVER 1-003-100-0800 NINETY
NINE A UNIQUE SMALL BUSINESS
SAYS IN YEAR THREE OF THE
PROGRAM I AND THE REPORTING IS
BASED ON THE METRICS THAT ARE
DEFINED DURING THE GRANT MAKING
PROCESS SO EACH GRANT AGREEMENT
FOR EACH CENTER OR NETWORK OF
CENTERS I DEFINE THE REPORTING
THAT WILL BE REQUIRED. DURING
THE PROGRAM HERE. AT THANK YOU
GIVEN THE CALIFORNIA WILL
RECEIVE ONE POINT TWO BILLION
AND FEDERAL STATE SMALL BUSINESS
CREDIT INITIATIVE FUNDS HOW WILL
THE TAPE SAID I HEARD ANOTHER
GROUP IT'S PROGRAMS BEFORE
NEEDED TO CREATE A PIPELINE. OF
SMALL BUSINESSES READY TO ACCESS
CAPITAL. WE WILL WE WILL
LEVERAGE ON THE ON THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PORTION AND THAT WE
WILL BE INVOLVED IN. I'LL WE
WILL LEVERAGE THIS VERY NETWORK-
THAT HAS SHOWN AT THROUGH THE
PANDEMIC AND WORK ON THAT SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE COULD BE
NINETEEN- RELIEF GRANT PROGRAM.
EXACTLY ACTUAL WEALTHY CAN WORK
NEEDS. WITH SOME OF BROWN'S USE
CASH. OUR TARGET. OKAY I'M GONNA
MISS GRATEFUL LIKE YU AND I ARE
GOING TO BECOME FAST FRIENDS
WHEN IT COMES TO ISSUES RELATED
TO DATA AND DATA BREAK DOWN A
CURRENTLY THE TAPE AND SUBTRACT
SERVICES MINORITY OWNED
BUSINESSES BUT DO NOT REPORT ANY
FURTHER DEMOGRAPHIC BREAKDOWNS
AT CAN ALWAYS BE EIGHT PROVIDE
THIS DATA OR REVISE THE PROGRAMS
TO REQUEST SUCH DATA IN THE
FUTURE YOU KNOW WHAT I'M GETTING
AT AND YOU KNOW THE REASONS WHY
CURIOUS AS TO HOW WE GET IT DONE
. I WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK WITH YOU I THINK IT SAYS WE
SHARE A SIMILAR DESIRE ON DATA
COLLECTION- TO PROVE THE
EFFICACY. OF OUR PROGRAMS WHICH
WE KNOW ARE WORKING. THE AND I
THINK THAT THAT'S THERE ARE
LIMITATIONS WHICH I EXPRESSED
EARLIER AND WE ARE- COLLECTING
THAT INFORMATION FOLLOWING TERRY
TERMS AND MANY OF OUR CENTERS DO
YOU COLLECT- FOR THEIR FEDERAL
REPORTING THEY DO COLLECT AND
OTHER ETHNIC AND RACE BASED
INFORMATION BUT AGAIN I'LL WORK
REQUIREMENTS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
NEED ASPIRIN REALLY COLLECTING
AND FRANKLY TAKING. ADVANTAGE OF
THAT INFORMATION. SO WE TO FIND
A- A WORK AROUND ON THAT SO THAT
WE HAVE BETTER DATA AND THE
LEGISLATURE CAN MAKE DECISIONS
BASED ON WHERE RESOURCES ARE
NEEDED AND HOW WE ULTIMATELY AT
THE END OF THE DAY SUPPORT SMALL
BUSINESSES WHICH IS WHAT WE ALL
WANT- LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU ON THAT AND FIGURING
THAT OUT AND ALSO LIKE ENSURING
THAT WE SEE THOSE REPORTS THAT
YOU CURRENTLY HAVE. TO GIVE US
ANY LARGER PERSPECTIVE AND
VIEWPOINT FROM YOUR POSITION AS
TO WHAT WORKS AND WHAT DOESN'T-
VERY A SIMILAR QUESTION JUST-
HOW DOES ALWAYS BE A OVERSEE
THAT TAPE AND SIP PROGRAMS TO
ENSURE HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED
BUSINESSES ARE REACH. AND WHAT
METRICS AND BAPE BENCHMARKS ARE
CURRENTLY USED TO TRACK SUCCESS
AND IDENTITY SERVICE DELIVERY
GAPS. SUE THE REASON WHY I AM
EXPANSION I IS IN MANY AREAS WE
HAVE REQUIRED EACH YEAR. IF THAT
APPLICANTS TO THE PROGRAM.
EXPANDS TO WIDER AND LARGER
AUDIENCE. THAT IS INCLUSIVE OF
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES LOW TO
MODERATE INCOME. INDIVIDUALS LOW
WEALTH COMMUNITIES. WOMEN AND-
VARIOUS DIFFERENT RURAL
GEOGRAPHIES. SO WE- ARE WORKING
NETWORK UNDERSTANDS VERY CLEARLY
THAT THIS IS OUR TARGET. I BAD
OR PROGRAMS EXIST TO HELP UP
LEFT ALL. MY BUSINESSES IN OUR
STATE AND IT IS A PRIORITY. AND
WILL CONTINUE TO BE OUT. THANK
YOU THAT AND I'M SO GLAD THAT
YOU UP- RULE COMMUNITIES I MY
DISTRICT- JUST TO SPEAK FRANKLY
FROM MY POSITION IN MY AREA
WHERE AN URBAN CITY OF LOS
ANGELES. VERY DIFFERENT NEEDS-
AND RESOURCE GAP SAYS IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE
WHETHER IT'S- AND ADDITIONALLY
TO LANGUAGE BARRIERS AND
TECHNOLOGY AND INTERNET AND ALL
OF THOSE THINGS I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT WERE IN ALIGNMENT
TO SOME OF THE QUESTIONS THAT
OTHER LEGISLATORS HAVE IN TERMS
OF OPPORTUNITIES AND RESOURCES
FOR THEIR DISTRICTS AS WELL.
THANK YOU AGAIN SO MUCH FOR-
THAT THE OPPORTUNITY TO CONNECT
WITH YOU TODAY AS WE FIGURE OUT
FIGURE OUT NEXT STEPS. IF WE
HAVE THE L. A. O. ON THE LINE
MISTER WEATHERFORD ANY COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS. SORRY MANAGER THIS
IS BRIAN NAYLOR TRYING TO JUMP
ON FROM MY CALLING WHETHER FOR
LOST INTERNET CONNECTION- THANK
YOU I THINK- NO I THINK I DON'T
THINK WE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
WRITE. CAN I GO AHEAD- WE I
WOULD JUST NOTE ON THIS ITEM-
THAT- WHILE THERE APPEARS TO BE
A JUSTIFICATION FOR A PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL MONEY- THE
LEGISLATURE FACES A TRADE OFF IN
TERMS OF MAKING THE FUNDING
ONGOING VERSUS CONTINUING IT-
AND KIND OF TRUCKS AS A ONE TIME
FUNDING IN TERMS OF THE-
CREATING AN ACCOUNTABILITY
MECHANISM FOR THE ADMINISTRATION
TO COME BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE
AND- PROVIDE THE KIND OF DATA
AND IN THE END OF VALUATIONS
THAT THE SUB COMMITTEE WAS WAS
JUST. REQUESTING A DIFFERENT
VERSION. THANK YOU NOW WITH THE
- I PUT MYSELF ON ME AT NO
ADDITIONAL. OF QUESTIONS WE CAN
MOVE ON CAN BE ONE MOMENT
PLEASE- MISTER SYRIAN HAD A
QUESTION BUT HE STEPPED OUT SO
ONE CAN BE ONE MOMENT. MISS GRAY
IF YOU DON'T MIND- JUST HOLDING
ON FOR A COUPLE OF MINUTES- WE I
WANT TO GIVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MY COLLEAGUE MISTER NECESSARY
AND TO ASK A QUESTION RELATED TO
ISSUE ONE BUT IF HE DOES NOT
COME BACK BEFORE WE CONCLUDE
WITH ISSUE NINE- WILL MOVE
FORWARD BUT THANK YOU AGAIN IF
YOU DON'T MIND WAITING JUST A
COUPLE OF MINUTES. LET'S GO TO-
ISSUE NUMBER NINE THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR THIS PANEL IS ISSUE
NUMBER NINE HUMAN RESOURCES
STAFFING. MISTER JAMES- TO HAN
BUT SAID THAT CORRECTLY GUESSED.
YES IT'S MINOR GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS Y NAME IS JIM
TÌM. AND I WORK AS CHIEF
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES DIVISION
FOR GOBIZ. AND WHAT WE'RE
REQUESTING IS A HUNDRED AND TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS I'M GOING
GENERAL FUND TO INCREASE THE
GLOBE AS HUMAN RESOURCES BY ONE
POSITION. A NUMBER OF POSITIONS
AT GLOBE IS INCREASED BY 66%
OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS. AS
ALLEGED LEGISLATURE HAS
INCREASED RESPONSIBILITIES OF
THE APARTMENT. AS NOTED BY THE
L. A. L. MANAGEMENT IN GENERAL
ADMINISTRATIVE EXPENSES
TYPICALLY FOLLOW INCREASES IN
APARTMENT A PROGRAM LIKE.
RESPONSIBILITIES SO PRETTY
STRAIGHTFORWARD I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. BUT I'LL
ANY COMMENTS QUESTIONS. WE DON'T
HAVE ANY CONCERNS ON THIS
PROPOSAL THANK YOU THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MYSTERONS
AND- NOTHING TO ADD AT THIS TIME
. MISTER LUCKY YEAH I JUST HAD A
REAL QUICK A CLARIFYING
QUESTION- ON THE BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL STATES THAT THERE A
HUNDRED SEVENTY FOUR POSITIONS
FOR THE CURRENT YEAR. BUT GOMEZ
ONLY HAS A HUNDRED THIRTY THREE
POINT THREE AUTHORIZED POSITIONS
CAN YOU HELP ME UNDERSTAND THE-
DISCREPANCY THERE. IN FACT THIS
QUESTION WAS ANSWERED BY
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LET ME
READ WITH THEIR ANSWER WAS GIVEN
THE GALLERY INCLUDES BUDGET
POSITION TRANSPARENCY WE INTEND
TO DO TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS IN
THE SPRING TO UNWIND POSITIONS.
THE SALARIES AND WAGES
DOCUMENTED IN POINT IN TIME
APPEARS TO BE A BETTER SENSE
TOTAL FILLED AUTHORIZED HE
PROPOSED POSITIONS AND THEY IN
TURN ATTACHED THE TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
SALARIES AND WAGES DOCUMENT.
WHICH OUR SCHEDULE SEVEN EIGHT
WHICH- TALK ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY POSITIONS. I GUESS
THAT'S BECAUSE I'M GONNA GET.
OKAY THANK YOU SIR. THANK YOU MR
LACKEY A WE ARE CONCLUDING. WE
ARE CONCLUDING- THIS PORTION AND
UNFORTUNATES FURNACE AREA AND
WAS NOT ABLE TO RETURN SO I WANT
TO THANK ALL OF THE PANELISTS
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION TODAY-
JUST AS A- BEFORE WE GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT ACTUALLY LET ME
GIVE OUT THAT INFORMATION-
QUICKLY WE ARE ACCEPTING PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THE AT. AT THIS
MOMENT BOTH IN THE HEARING ROOM
AND ON THE PHONE THE FULL THE
TOLL FREE NUMBER IS. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. PASS A PUBLIC ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
FOUR FOUR AS WE CONCLUDED FOR
TODAY'S. HEARING I'LL JUST SAY
THIS- BRIEFLY AS CHAIR OF
BUDGETS OF FOUR I CAN'T IN GOOD
CONSCIENCE- GO TO OUR OVERALL
SUB OUR OVERALL BUDGET COMMITTEE
AND THE CHAIR OF A BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND OUR COLLEAGUES-
AND- HAVE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
PROPOSALS FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION WHEN. BUDGET
TRAILER LANGUAGE WAS DUE TODAY
AND WE DON'T HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION AND SO- IT BRINGS UP
THE QUESTION OF JURISDICTION AS
WELL AS RESPONSIBILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. TO ENSURE THAT AS
WE MOVE FORWARD WITH US CERTAIN
PROPOSALS WE HAVE DETAILS THAT
ARE IMPORTANT- WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN.
PUBLIC DOLLARS THAT WE- DON'T
HAVE ANY INFORMATION ON AND SO
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO MAKE
DECISIONS AND- HAVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND HAVE DISCUSSIONS
OF WHAT IS POSSIBLE WHEN.
DEADLINES ARE MISSED AND WHEN
WE'RE ASKED TO POTENTIALLY MAYBE
WE WILL HAVE BUDGET TRAILER
LANGUAGE TWO WEEKS FROM NOW. SO
AGAIN I WOULD JUST SAY I WOULD
JUST STRESS THE IMPORTANCE OF
MEETING DEADLINES AND ENSURING
THAT THE LEGISLATURE- IS A
PARTNER IN THIS PROCESS AS WE
MOVE FORWARD- MISTER NAZARIAN
THANKS FOR COMING BACK OUT. LOVE
TO SEE IF MS GRAY IS STILL ON
NOT SURE THAT SHE IS BECAUSE WE
CONCLUDED BUT IF SHE IS MISS
GRAY ARE YOU STILL ON. YES MA'AM
I AM OKAY ARE JUST A COUPLE OF
FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS ON ISSUE ONE
FOR MISTER NAZARIAN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND- I DON'T WANT TO
REPEAT WHAT YOU MAY HAVE ALREADY
EXHAUSTED DURING THE COMMITTEE
DURING THE FIRST PART OF THE-
COMMITTEE HEARING THAT I MISSED
UNFORTUNATELY DUE TO MEETINGS.
BUT I JUST I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED YOU BRING AGENDA
USING THIS ITEM- THE RELIEF
GRANTS AND FOR US TO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS THEM. AND
YOU PROBABLY MAY HAVE ALREADY
HAS SOME OF THE QUESTIONS WHICH
WAS. WANTED TO KNOW A LITTLE BIT
MORE DETAIL ABOUT- THE AVERAGE
AMOUNT PER GRNT. AND ALSO WHICH
DISTRICTS GOT THEM UP AT AT AT
WHAT AMOUNTS AND JUST WANTED TO
UNDERSTAND BETTER. UP WITH SOME
OF THE CRITERIA ALSO WAS WHAT
CAN WE DO TO ALSO OFFER MORE
SUPPORT MAYBE FOR BUSINESSES. OF
GOING FORWARD BUT IT WAS
CRITICAL FOR US TO KNOW EXACTLY
OF. HOW MUCH WAS EXPENDED WHAT
CRITERIA AND- OF WHAT SOME OF
THE AVERAGES WERE SAID THAT
BECAUSE HAVE BETTER DATA. THAT
WAS GONNA BE THE GIST OF IT
THANK YOU. DESCRIBE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO COULD RESPOND. YES MADAM
CHAIR I WILL- TO JUST A QUICK
RECAP FOR YOU STERN- AS OF
JANUARY TWENTY EIGHTH ON WE'VE
HAD. THREE HUNDRED TWELVE
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY ONE
AWARDS TOTALING THREE BILLION
FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY SEVEN
MILLION 700-406-0008 HUNDRED
EIGHTY FOUR DOLLARS. ON THE AND
EACH OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THAT HAS RECEIVED A BREAK DOWN
OF ALL THE AWARDS IN YOUR
INDIVIDUAL DISTRICT AND THE
SUMMARIES TO- HAVE BEEN INCLUDED
BACKGROUND AS WELL AS EACH
INDIVIDUAL BUSINESS AWARD AND
ALSO DO YOU WANT TO KNOW. BACK
TO UNVEILED NINE WARDS ARE STILL
BEING MADE AND AT ANY TIME YOU
CAN CHECK THE AWARD STATED THAT
POSTED ON OUR WEBSITE UNDER
PUBLICATIONS I'M WITH RESPECT TO
YOUR- SPECIFIC QUESTION ABOUT
ANNOUNCE ON THAT IS A NUMERICAL
FIGURE CALCULATED ACROSS ON ALL
OF THE GRANT AWARDS AND THE
AVERAGE. AWARD AMOUNT IS
CALCULATED AT ELEVEN THOUSAND
ONE HUNDRED DOLLARS AND THAT
JUST AS A CENTER STREET
NUMERICAL. I AVERAGE. THANK YOU
OF WAS THIS A THE AVERAGE
ACTUALLY ON THE WEBSITE AS WELL
. I KNOW D. I DON'T BELIEVE WE
HAVE THE ABORIGINAL AND AWARDS
SIZED. THERE YOU TYPICALLY JUST
ADD PEGS THE AWARD STATE ACT.
OKAY IT'LL BE WITHOUT CREATING A
SENSE OF COMPETITION HERE
MICHAEL ISN'T THAT BUT MY GOAL
IS TO BETTER UNDERSTAND. ALSO
HOW WHICH DISTRICTS GOT WHAT
FUNDING. SO THAT WE'RE WE'RE
BETTER- UNDERSTANDING WHERE THE
NEEDS ARE- WHICH SECTORS OF
INDUSTRY RECEIVED MORE ATTENTION
UP WHERE SOME AREAS WE NEED TO
LOOK AT MORE CAREFULLY- AND I'M
HAPPY TO ALSO ASK THESE
QUESTIONS OFFLINE IF YOU'D LIKE
TO SET UP SOME TIME BUT I AM I
INTERESTED TO KNOW RANKING WISE
WHAT EVERY SINGLE ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT RECEIVED. AND ALSO WHAT
SECTORS BENEFITED MOST. OF WARY
AND WHERE YOU'RE SEEING CERTAIN
OUTCOMES BASED ON DISEASE FUNDS
PROVIDED. ARE YOU KEEPING TABS
ON WHICH OF THESE BUSINESSES
HAVE ARE STILL OPEN OR CLOSED.
AND SO I CAN GO ON THROUGH THESE
QUESTIONS BUT THESE ARE THE
MYRIAD OF THAT'S THE THINKING I
HAVE AND SO I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT- THERE ISN'T GOING TO
BE AN ARTICLE FOR EXAMPLE. IN
SIX MONTHS FROM NOW THAT SAYS.
UP 20% OF THE BUSINESSES THAT WE
PAID GRANT RELIEFS TO CLOSE DOWN
WITHIN. TWO MONTHS TIME AFTER
RECEIVING THOSE GRANTS TO IT
SOME OF THESE THINGS THAT I JUST
WANT TO KNOW HOW WE'RE KEEPING.
CONTROL CHECKS ALSO OF WHAT THE
SUCCESSES OF THESE BUSINESSES.
THAT THAT SO THIS IS THE GENERAL
LINE OF THINKING I'M HAPPY TO
ASK MORE QUESTIONS EITHER
OFFLINE OR UP WHEN YOU HAVE MORE
DATA IN FRONT OF YOU AS WELL.
YES SIR I'M COMPLETELY
UNDERSTOOD IT WE APPRECIATE YOUR
APPROACH ON FIRST I'D LIKE TO
LET YOU KNOW THAT THE DVD IS
AVAILABLE BY DISTRICT GENERAL
FIRST SEE I'M HAS BEEN PROVIDING
THAT. INFORMATION TO OUR
REPRESENTATIVES ACROSS THE STATE
AND I'M MORE THAN HAPPY. AND TAX
INFORMATION ON HOLD FOR YOU ON
ADDITIONALLY WE MAY IN LAND ALL
THE REPORTS DATA SO I SLICE
COULD BE TAKEN AND YOU KNOW
ACROSS MULTIPLE DISTRICTS AND
THAT INFORMATION IS AVAILABLE WE
ALSO HAVE ON A SEPARATE REPORT
THAT DETAILS DEMOGRAPHICS.
DISTRIBUTION AND- THE INDUSTRY
DISTRIBUTION AND I'M HAPPY TO
SHARE THAT INFORMATION WITH YOU
AS WELL I'M A HAPPY TO WORK WITH
YOU OFFLINE TO GET ALL OF YOUR
QUESTIONS ANSWERED REGARDING THE
PROGRAM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
OBVIOUSLY WE'LL DO IT THROUGH
MADAM CHAIR SO THAT SHE HAS THE
INFORMATION AS WELL AND CAN
DISSEMINATED TO ALL THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND I APOLOGIZE. FOR
RUNNING LATE NOT BEINGABLE TO
ASK THESE QUESTIONS. BEFORE
DURING THE HEARING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER IS
THERE ANYTHING IT TO THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE FOR ALL OF YOUR
INPUT AND INSIGHT- MISTER
UPGRADER LET'S OR MADAM OPERATOR
LET'S BEGIN WITH THE I'M SORRY
WE ACTUALLY HAVE TESTIMONY IN
THE ROOM. LET'S BEGIN. THANK YOU
CHAIR CREWMEMBERS ALEX FOR AS A
STRATEGY THREE SIXTY HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
INDEPENDENT VENUE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR DISCUSSION ON THE US SMALL
BUSINESS RELIEF GRANTS BUT
ESPECIALLY. THE LIVE EVENT
VENUES GRANT. FIRST AND FOREMOST
I WANT TO THANK DIRECTOR GRADE
HER TEAM FOR THEIR ATTENTION
RESPONSE TO THE CONCERNS THE
CALIFORNIA AND OUR COALITION
PARTNERS CALIFORNIA ARTS
ADVOCATES INCOME AND PROFITS
HAVE RAISED- ON THAT GRANT
PROGRAM IN A LETTER WE SUBMITTED
TO THE ADMINISTRATION IN
DECEMBER. AS WELL AS TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE I WE'RE REALLY
CONFIDENT WE'LL BE ABLE TO
RESOLVE THE CHALLENGES WITHIN
THE SCOPE OF KALAS BY MINISTRIES
AUTHORITY BUT- WOULD NOTE SOME
OF THESE ISSUES DO REQUIRE
LEGISLATIVE ACTION TO AMEND THE
STATUTORY GUIDELINES THAT ARE
PROVEN TO BE INADVERTENT
BARRIERS TO WORTHY APPLICANTS
FROM GETTING CRITICALLY NEEDED
RELIEF ESPECIALLY AS THE OMICRON
VARIANT. HAS BECAUSE WE NEED TO
SHUT DOWN FESTIVALS AND SHOWS
CAN BE DELAYED- AND TREMENDOUS
CUSTOMER CONCERN AROUND LARGE
GATHERINGS. SOME OF THESE
CONCERNS- WE NOTED LIKELY WILL
IMPACT THE OVER FOUR HUNDRED
APPLICANTS CRRENTLY IN REVIEW-
NAMELY THE USE OF THE NORTH
AMERICAN INDUSTRY INDUSTRY
CLASSIFICATION CODES THE NEXT
CODES- AND OTHER CONCERNS WE- WE
DETAILED IN THE LETTER WE LOOK
FORWARD TO DRAWING DOWN ON THAT-
ON A SOLUTION TOGETHER- YOU
KNOW. THAT COLLABORATIVELY WITH
CALLASPO AND THE LEGISLATURE TO
SEE IF PERHAPS WE CAN GET SOME
EARLY BUDGET ACTION ITEM ON
THIS- SIMPLY PUT WE'RE FOCUSED
ON MAKING SURE THE DOLLARS IN
THE PROGRAM ARE MAXIMIZED TO THE
GREATEST EXTENT WHAT WE'RE
WORRIED ABOUT IS THE EXISTENCE
OF LEFT OR- LEFT OVER FUNDS FROM
THIS PROGRAM THAT COULD HAVE
GONE OVER THE APPLICANTS- THAT-
THAN CALL UP CLOUD BACK- IN
THESE DOCUMENTS DON'T GET A
CHANCE. BECAUSE OF SOME OF THESE
DISQUALIFIER IS. LIKE LIKE I
SAID THE ONLY COUNTRY IN IS
REALLY THROWING A WRENCH INTO
THE PLANS FOR FULL REOPEN MISTER
NAZARIAN YOU TOUCHED ON. A ONE
INDUSTRIES ARE OPEN WHAT WHICH-
WHICH INDUSTRIES MAY STILL BE
CLOSER FOR PEACE IN SOME SORT
OF- GUIDELINES WITH CAPACITY
RESTRICTIONS- BUT WE UNDERSTAND
IT'S NO IT'S NO SMALL FEAT TO
ROLL OUT ALL THESE PROGRAMS THAT
CAUSE BUT THAT KOBE IS-
L'INDUSTRIE IS HELPING
ADMINISTER SO. REALLY JUST WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE.
THE TIME THAT THE ATTENTION OF
THE CONCERNS WE REYES AND LOOK
FOR. TO THE ON PARTNERS SESSION
TO BE HOT THANK YOU SO MUCH. I
APPRECIATE THANK YOU KNOW WHEN I
IN THE ROOM LET'S GO TO THE
PHONE LINE- PLEASE JOIN ME IF
YOU'D LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENTS PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. YEAH WE DO A FEW
IN OUR QUEUE ALREADY. WE'LL
START WITH A LINE OF ONE OH TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- THIS IS MORE
A TOP ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SAN DIEGO. SPEAKING TO ISSUE
NUMBER THREE- WE ARE IN AND
TRONG SUPPORT OF THE ITEM. OF
COURSE AND THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
GRANTS ARE- AN IMPORTANT
COMPONENT OF IT WE LOOK FORWARD
TO. WORKING WITH AND THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION ON HOW THAT
PROGRAM IS CRAFTED. BUT WE
REALLY DO VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE ENTIRE PROPOSAL- AND THE
EMPHASIS ON ON THE BORDER
REGION. IS APPROPRIATE AND WE
THINK VITALLY NEEDED- WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT AND THE
FACT THAT. THE BORDER REGION-
HASN'T RECEIVED A- SIGNIFICANT-
INFUSION OF RESOURCES. AND SAN
DIEGO IS ARE NOT JUST THE
LARGEST BORDER CITY AND IN
CALIFORNIA BUT IT'S THE LARGEST
BORDER CITY IN THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY SO WITH THAT WE VERY
MUCH SUPPORT. ON THE PROPOSAL
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING OUR
PARTNERSHIP- WITH YOU AND WITH
OUR OUR OUR SISTER- COUNTRY- TO
THE SOUTH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU AND JUST A POINT OF
CLARIFICATION- TELEPHONE
TESTIMONY IS LIMITED TO ONE
MINUTE AND WE HAVE SEVERAL
CALLERS SO LET'S KEEP IT MOVING
OPERATOR. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS TERAFLOPS
AND REPRESENTING THE TEAMSTERS
PORT DIVISION ON ISSUE FIVE ON
SUPPLY CHAIN RESILIENCE AND I
WANT TO SPECIFICALLY COMMENT ON
THE CREATION OF A STATE WIDE
DATA PORTAL TO INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY DATA COLLECTION AND
DATA SHARING. WE WOULD URGE
LEGISLATORS AND GOBIZ TO
INCLUDE- IF THIS PROPOSAL MOVES
FORWARD THE COLLECTION AND
SHARING OF DATA SPECIFICALLY ON
PORT TACK PORT TRUCK DRIVER
EMPLOYMENT STATUS AND JOB
QUALITY. THIS STATE IS
ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL TO CLEAR
THE BACKLOG THAT THE PORTS AND
CREATE A MORE EFFICIENT SYSTEM
THAT POSSIBLE SUPPORTS THE
TRANSITION TO ZERO EMISSIONS
VEHICLES THAT MEET CLIMATE GOALS
IN WHICH THE STATE HAS A VERY
CLEAR INTEREST AND THE REASON
THE STATE IS SO CRUCIAL IS
BECAUSE- THE MISS CLASSIFICATION
OF PORT TRUCK DRIVERS. IS
RAMPANT AND HAS BEEN A SOURCE OF
CONGESTION AND DELAYED FOR YEARS
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC AND THE
FRACTURED NATURE OF THE TRADE
INDUSTRY MAKES IT IMPOSSIBLE TO
SCHEDULE EMPLOYMENT APPOINTMENT
AND HAVE DRIVERS SHOW UP ON TIME
TO MAKE THE ATTEMPT-
APPOINTMENTS. AND EVEN THOUGH
COMPANIES EXERT OVERWHELMING
CONTROL OVER MISCLASSIFIED
DRIVERS THEY'RE STILL UNABLE TO
RETAIN A STABLE WORK FORCE TO
TRACTOR DEPLOY EIGHT TRUCK
DRIVER SUFFICIENTLY- OR DO ANY
OF THE THINGS THAT WE NEED TO
KEEP A GLOBAL PORT RUNNING
SMOOTHLY- AND SO A CENTRALIZED
DATA POOR PORTAL AND THE
COLLECTION AND SHARING OF THIS
DATA WOULD BE HELPFUL AND IN THE
STATE'S INTEREST. BECAUSE IT
WOULD MAKE IT EASIER TO ENFORCE
LAWS ON MISS CLASSIFICATION SUCH
AS THE CHAIRS THE BILL THAT'S
NOW LAW EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY FOUR
AND SB THREE THIRTY EIGHT IT
WOULD HELP ELIMINATE FRICTION IN
THE SYSTEM. AND THROUGH THE RE
CLASSIFICATION OF TRUCK DRIVERS
INCREASE THE ABILITY OF TRUCKING
COMPANIES TO EFFICIENTLY
SCHEDULE AND DEPLOY THEIR FLEETS
OF TRUCKS TWENTY FORTY SEVEN IF
NECESSARY. TO ADDRESS THE
BACKLOG. AND IT WOULD ALSO FOR
THE- OF WE ARE. ARE WE CAN DRIVE
TO THAT TO THAT AREA. AND SO WE
WOULD SAY THAT THE PRICING
RESILIENCE STARTS WITH
TRANSPARENCY IN DATA THAT GIVES
THE INFORMATION TO CRAFT
POLICIES TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE
AND STARTING WITH TRACKING PORT
TRUCK DRIVERS WHO ARE REALLY KEY
PART OF LOGISTICS CHAIN. WILL
NOT ONLY HELP WITH CLEARING THE
BACKLOG BUT ALSO GIVE
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES A POWERFUL
TOOL TO ENFORCE OUR LABOR AND
ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS AT THE
STATE'S PORTS- SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
THIS PROPOSAL. I'M SHAPING IT
AND FEEL IT IS VERY MUCH IN THE
STATE'S INTEREST THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT CALLER.
NEXT DEADLINE ONE SIXTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. OKAY THERE ARE
DUPLICATE CHECKS FROM CRUISE
STRATEGIES ON BEHALF OF
WESTFIELD IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT
INCLUDES TWENTY MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND FOR GOLD IS TO
DEVELOP AND DISTRIBUTE GRANTS TO
SMALL BUSINESSES THAT HAVE BEEN
THE VICTIM OF RETAIL STORE STUFF
FOR DAMAGE CAUSED DURING WE TALK
ABOUT THE INCIDENT. ON BEHALF OF
WEST BUILDING WANTED TO SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
. NEXT TO BE ADELINE SEVENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HEALTHY THE
CARTER WITH CALDERON PROFITS
COMMENTING ON ISSUE ONE I WANT
TO THANK THE LEGISLATURE
ADMINISTRATION FOR INCLUDING NON
PROFITS IN THE CALLOUS MALL
BUSINESS KOPET RELIEF GRANT
PROGRAM AND THE CALIFORNIA
VENUES GRANTS PROGRAM THOUSANDS
OF NONPROFITS RECEIVED GRANTS TO
BOTH PROGRAMS INCLUDING MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS- TO HELP THE SECTOR.
AS YOU KNOW NONPROFIT HAVE
RESPONDED AND CONTINUE TO
RESPOND TO THE GROWING NEEDS OF
OUR COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC NONPROFITS CONTINUE TO
FACE ECONOMIC HARDSHIPS WITH
INCREASED NEED FOR SERVICES AND
MANY FACTORS ONGOING CLOSER THAN
OTHERS AND HIGHER PROGRAMMATIC
COSTS ACROSS THE BOARD. WE ARE
PLEASED TO HEAR THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET
INCLUDES ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR
THE SMALL BUSINESS COACH RELIEF
GRANT PROGRAM TO SUPPORT ONGOING
FUNDING. BUT FOR ARTS
ORGANIZATIONS CULTURAL
INSTITUTIONS AND PERFORMANCE
VENUES IN ASKING THE LEGISLATURE
TO DO THE FOLLOWING KEEP THE
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS REMAINING
FROM THE ORIGINAL FIFTY MILLION
FOR CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS IN A
SEPARATE PART OF FUNDS FOR THESE
INSTITUTIONS WHICH FACE ONGOING
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES. TO OFFER
ADDITIONAL ROUNDS OF CULTURAL
INSTITUTION GRANTS THAT ALLOW
FOR SECOND GRANT FOR THE
NEEDIEST ORGANIZATIONS THREE
KEEP ANY RESIDUAL FUNDING FROM
THE VENUE'S GRANT PROGRAM IN A
SEPARATE POT FOR VENUES THEY ARE
FACING ONGOING CLOSURES PLEASE
READ OUR ELIMINATE THAT MAKES.
ELIMINATE THE NEXT CODE
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS AND
FIVE ENSURE FLEXIBILITY WITH
REGARD TO TAX FORMS WE WANT TO
THANK YOU ON BEHALF OF CAL
NONPROFITS IN OUR TEN THOUSAND
PLUS MEMBERS FOR YOUR ONGOING
SUPPORT OF NONPROFITS. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER IN PLEASE LIMIT
YOUR- TESTIMONY TO ONE MINUTE.
NEXEO DO NUMBER. NINETY NINE.
HELLO MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE MONEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRAVEL ASSOCIATION
THAT. AND FOR THE STATE'S TRAVEL
AND TOURISM INDUSTRY. I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE TO
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
ALLOCATION OF FORTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO EXPAND BUT THE
CALIFORNIA'S MARKETING
CAMPAIGNS. CONTINUED INVESTMENT
IS CRITICAL AS THE TOURISM
ECONOMY ESPECIALLY IN URBAN
CENTERS EXPERIENCES A LOPSIDED
RECOVERY THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU NICE COLOR. CYSTIC THE
SEVEN. YES GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ARMAND FELICIANO IN THE APP THAT
CALIFORNIA HOTEL AND LODGING
ASSOCIATION WOULD LIKE TO
COMMENT ON ISSUE NUMBER TWO
RELATED TO TOURISM RECOVERY S
C. H. L. A. SUPPORTS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL SPENT FORTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND. EXTENDED CAB POINT MEDIA
CAMPAIGNS TO CONTINUE ATTRACTING
VISITORS TO CALIFORNIA AT THIS
SECTOR OF THE ECONOMY CONTINUES
TO HAVE AN AND EVEN RECOVERY AB
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTS COMMITTEE
APPROVED IT'S- AN APPROPRIATE.
THANK YOU. THANK NICE COLOR.
NEXT TO BE NUMBER EIGHTY FOUR.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND- DIRECTOR GRADE THIS
IS LORI KAMMER SMALL BUSINESS
CALIFORNIA AND ALSO WEBER
REPRESENTING NAPO CALIFORNIA
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF WOMEN
BUSINESS OWNERS- REGARDING
BUDGET ISSUE EIGHT- ON THE
CALIFORNIA SB EIGHT- I REQUEST
THE- ON THE MATCHING
REQUIREMENTS THE FEDERAL
RECIPIENTS OF THE TAPE PROGRAM
CURRENTLY HAVE TO MATCH THE
PROGRAM AT TO THE ONE OR FIVE OH
ONE SEE THREE RECIPIENTS. ONLY
HAVE TO MATCH THE PROGRAM AT ONE
TO ONE RATIO THIS PUTS THE
FEDERAL PROGRAMS AT A
DISADVANTAGE AND RISK SENDING
UNMATCHED FEDERAL DOLLARS OUT OF
OUR STATE WE RECOMMEND A ONE
POINT ONE MATCH FOR ALL TAKE
PERCIPIENT. FEDERAL OR NON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS- ON
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS WE
RECOMMEND ALLOWING REASONABLE
ADMINISTRATIVE EXPENSES WITHIN
THE TAPE FUNDING AND IF THERE IS
AN OVER SUBSCRIPTION OF THE TAPE
PROGRAM WE RECOMMEND THAT
FEDERALLY FUNDED PROGRAMS HAVE A
PRIORITY TO THE TAPE FUNDING AT
THESE DOLLARS LEVERAGE THE
ABILITY TO KEEP FEDERAL
TECHNICAL EQUIPMENT FUNDING IN
THE STATE. AND THEN FINALLY IN
THE EXPANSION- WE ARE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THE RECOMMENDATION-
TO EXPAND TAPED TO CONTINUE THE
PROGRAM- INDEFINITELY SO THAT WE
DON'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT A
SUNSET IN THE PROGRAM CAN
CONTINUE TO DO ALL OF THE GREAT
WORK- THAT THE TAPE PROVOKE
PROGRAM PROVIDES TO OUR MEMBERS
WHO ARE SMALL BUSINESSES AND.
WOMEN OWNED BUSINESSES THANK YOU
. THANK YOU NEXT. NOW GO. TO
SIXTY EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS LAURA MAY AND I'M
THINKING I'M HAPPY CALIFORNIA AT
THE AGE OF THE PORT AUTHORITY
PARK. WHICH REPRESENTS
CALIFORNIA'S ELEVEN COURT. KAPPA
IS IN TRONG ORGANIZATION BY
DEFENSE TODAY A THIRTY MILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT WILL
FIND OPERATIONAL. AND THAT ARE
MADE BEFORE. DURING THE CALL THE
AND THEN MAKING PORT STEP UP AND
PLAYED A CRITICAL ROLE IN
CALIFORNIA'S RESPONSE TO
RECOVERY REPORTS HAVE BEEN
CRITICAL IN KEEPING CARGO AN
ESSENTIAL GOOD FALLING IN A TIME
WHEN OUR COUNTRY IS DEPENDENT ON
EFFICIENT. SUPPLY CHAIN MORE
THAN EVER. WHAT WE NEED A
GREATER. IN ORACLE IS. ADDITION
THE IN THE- FOR. BONTA THING TO
GROWING BALLING. WHICH WILL
MODEL IMPROVE THE CORPORATE. BUT
ALSO ADDS JOBS AND BOLSTER.
ACTIVITY. WELCOME SURE THAT ARE
QUITE CONTINUE TO COMMIT TO OUR
STEWARDSHIP BY LORNE MISSION.
THANK YOU FOR THE UP TO I THANK
YOUNG THE COURT THE BUDGET AND
WE CAN LOOK FORWARD TO CAN
WORKING YOU. THANK YOU OUR NEXT
CALL. WELL NOW GO TO NUMBER ONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN MEMBERS I
AM WITHOUT THE CHECKER WITH THE
LOS ANGELES AREA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WE ARE THE RECIPIENTS
OF THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
EXPANSION PROGRAM FUNDING WHICH
ALLOWED US TO HELP OUR HARD
WORKING SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
AND ENTREPRENEURS ACROSS THE LOS
ANGELES REGION THE ALLEY
CHAMBERS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
ITEMS TWO FOUR. SIX AND EIGHT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NUMBER EIGHTY
SEVEN. CHECK THAT A. L. AND
NUMBER THREE IN THE UNITED
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF STATE POLICY
AND ADVOCACY AT LACK OF ACTION
FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHT I
WANT TO PROVIDE A FEW GENERAL
COMMENTS AND SUPPORT MANAGING
THE ITEM THREE RELATED TO
IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION I HAVE
WORKED FOR MANY YEARS TO ADVANCE
INTEGRATION EFFORTS WITHIN OUR
STATE AND WE FEEL WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN OTHER STATES
ACROSS THE NATION HAVE ALREADY
MADE THE SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT
BANK THE PHYSICALLY AND
IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION IN THEIR
GOVERNMENT STRUCTURE. WE WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR FOR HER COMMENT
ON MAKING SURE WE HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE HUMAN INFRASTRUCTURE
IN PLACE TO ACCOMPLISH ALL OF
THESE MEANINGFUL CHANGES AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF PROGRAM WE
BELIEVE THIS IS THE KEY TO THAT
THE FACT THAT EACH OF THE
HIGHLIGHTED PIECES AND YOU CAN
THAT AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING ALONGSIDE THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE THIS COMMITTEE TO
BRING IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION WORK
AND STRUCTURE PERMANENTLY ANTI.
GOVERNMENT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT TO
NUMBER SEVENTY FIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO AND BUDGET COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MIKE DANIEL
AND I'M THE NETWORK DIRECTOR OF
THE ORANGE COUNTY INLAND EMPIRE
SBDC AND THE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA AT THE PROGRAM. OVER
THE PAST SEVEN YEARS THE
TECHNICAL EXTENSION PROGRAM AND
CAPITAL FUTURE PROGRAM HELLO THE
CALIFORNIA PROGRAM TO MORE THAN
DOUBLE IN SIZE AT DANCE TODAY
THE COMPANY AT THE PROGRAM IS
ONE THE LARGEST BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS IN THE
COUNTRY EQUITY FIFTY FULL TIME
SERVICE CENTERS THIRTY SIX
SATELLITE OFFICES. IF YOU NINE
OUT REDUPLICATION ALTOGETHER WE
HAVE A HUNDRED SIXTY LOCATIONS
ACROSS THE STATE THIRTEEN AT THE
DC IN EVERY COUNTY AND IN MOST
CITIES ACROSS THE STATE OUR
PROGRAM HAS GROWN MORE THAN
TWELVE HUNDRED BUSINESS
CONSULTANT TO CONTEST THE
BUSINESS OWNERS AND BUSINESS
EXPERTS WHO ARE ALL LOCAL TO
THEIR COMMUNITY THAT THEY THIRD
AT. BEFORE THE TWENTY FIVE PLUS
LANGUAGES. OUR TYPICAL QUITE A
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER BUT LEFT
THE FIVE EMPLOYEES. AND LEADS
THAN TWO HUNDRED FIFTH THOUSAND.
IN SALES. WITH THE TAPE AND THE
I. P. PROGRAMS WE ARE. IN THE
EXACT TYPE OF UNDERSERVED PUBLIC
DEFENDER THAT YOU'RE SPEAKING
ABOUT TODAY. LOCAL TAYLOR THE
COMMUNITY BAKERY AND RESTAURANT
THE LOCAL CORNER STORE. THE HOME
CHALK IT DOES NOT AND THOUSANDS
OF OTHERS. WE THAT THAT THE DOT
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESSES BUT
ACT THAT THE THREE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS IN DEBT AND
EQUITY CAPITAL. INCLUDING ALL
FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL DISASTER
RELIEF PROGRAMS INCLUDING PPP.
IDLE. AND THE CALIFORNIA RELIEF
GRANT. IT PROGRAMS OF THE CAL AT
THE ALONG WITH OUR OTHER. BUT
DEVELOPMENT. THAT YOU'RE WBT.
THE MP V. PAY TAX. AND OTHERS TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF BOB COMMITTEE
BEFORE AND DURING THE PANDEMIC.
WE FEEL THAT THERE'S NO BETTER
TIME THAN NOW TO MAKE THE CASE
THAT THE I. P. PROGRAMS
PERMANENT. AND MAKE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESSES HAVE
THE RESOURCES THEY NEED. TO GET
THROUGH THE PANDEMIC AND TRIED
IN THE FUTURE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND COMMITMENT TO
CALIFORNIA FATHER. THANK YOU
NEXT. NEXT IS THE ONE NINETEEN.
CANONSBURG PROPOSED ON THE
HEALTH OF THE CALIFORNIA ARTS
ADVOCATE SPEAKING ON ISSUE ONE
WE WANT TO THANK THE LEGISLATURE
ADMINISTRATION FOR INCLUDING
HELP WITH ART AND CULTURE
NONPROFIT SHE CREATED BUSINESSES
AND CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS
COMPANY JIM LEACH GRANT PROGRAMS
IN THE CALIFORNIA VENUES GRANT
PROGRAM A PLEASE SEE THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET
INCLUDES ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR
THE CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS
COVER NINETEEN BILLY GRANT
PROGRAMS TO KEEP ON GOING
FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAM WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE FOLLOWING. EVEN THE
TWENTY MILLION REMAIN FOM THE
ORIGINAL FIFTY MILLION FOR COAL
TRANSPORTATION THAN A SEPARATE
POCKET FUNDS FOR THE
INSTITUTIONS OFFER ADDITIONAL
ROUNDS OF CULTURAL INSTITUTION
GRANTS AND ALLOW FOR SECOND
GRANT FOR THE MEDIA
ORGANIZATIONS KEEP ANY RESIDUAL
FUNDING COME ALIVE AND GRANT
PROGRAM AND A SEPARATE PUBLIC
VENUES AT THE KITCHEN I'M GOING
CULTURE HELLO NAY THE NEXT OF
YOUR BODY REQUIRES TO ENSURE.
WITH REGARD TO TAX REFORM A LOT
FOR UNIQUE NONPROFIT
DOCUMENTATION IN THE CLEAR
DIFFERENCES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT
WILL BE NUMBERS TWO. GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIRMAN SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS
FOR THE TIME TO COMMENT ON HOW
TO MAKE THE TACKLE SUBSTANCE
EXPANSION PROGRAM MY NAME IS JIM
WATSON I'M THE PRESIDENT AND CEO
OF THE CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURING
TECHNOLOGY CONSULTING WE ARE
NONPROFIT FEDERALLY FUNDED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF COMMERCE TO BE
THE MANUFACTURING EXTENSION
PARTNERSHIP CENTER FOR
CALIFORNIA. FOCUSING EXCLUSIVELY
ON PROVIDING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND TRAINING FOR
SMALL AND MEDIUM SIZE
MANUFACTURERS WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING
OF COURTESY OF THE OF THE
TECHNICAL SUPPORT EXPANSION
PROGRAM AS A PROVIDE FUNDING TO
ADDRESS THE CHALLENGES FACING
THE MORE THAN SEVENTY SIX OTHER
MINORITY FIFTY FOUR HUNDRED
WOMEN AND FOURTEEN HUNDRED
VETERAN OWNED MANUFACTURED IN
CALIFORNIA. AND ALSO PROVIDES
FUNDING TO ADDRESS THE
CHALLENGES OF THE SIX THOUSAND
MANUFACTURERS LOCATED DISASTERS
IN THE FIFTEEN HUNDRED LOCATED
IN GLOBAL AFFAIRS AND WORLD AS
WELL 79% OF THESE MANUFACTURERS
HAVE LESS THAN TWENTY EMPLOYEES
. OF THE BUSINESS IN MOST NEED
OF ASSISTANCE WITH CRITICAL
CHALLENGES SUCH AS MAINTAINING A
SAFE WORKPLACE CONTROLLING COSTS
pSUPPLY CHAIN DISRUPTIONS THAT
ARE DELAYING CRITICAL MATERIALS
THEY NEED TO MAKE THEIR PRODUCTS
AND FINDING SKILLED WORKERS THAT
ALLOW THEM TO OTHER COMPANIES TO
ADOPT NEW TECHNOLOGIES NEEDED TO
SURVIVE. PROVIDING ASSISTANCE IN-THESE AREAS WILL ENABLE GROPING. CREATE HIGH PAYING JOBS. WHAT
MANY FACTS COMMITTEE I
APPRECIATE YOUR CAN YOU TO
CONTINUE SUPPORT OF PROGRAM
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
. NEXT WE GO TO NUMBER. ONE
TWENTY. TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MOVED TO LINE ONE TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NUMBER ONE
TWENTY FIVE REALIZE OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR CARILLO THIS
DAVID NELSON AND MEMBERS THE
GREAT DEPRESSION DAVID NELSON
DIRECTOR POLICY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASIA PACIFIC CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE- REALLY APPRECIATE
THIS HEARING TODAY AND CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE SMALL
BUSINESS TECHNICAL TO EXPANSION
PROGRAM WE'RE VERY VERY
ENCOURAGED- BY THE PRIORITY OF
THE ADMINISTRATION TO MAKE THIS
A PERMANENT PROGRAM- WE CERTAIN
. REPRESENT OVER SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND API OWN BUSINESSES AND
WE APPRECIATE THE LEADERSHIP OF
BELL BIDS IN- ALLOCATING
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THE
PROGRAM AS IT IS HAS BEEN
CONSISTENTLY OVER SUBSCRIBED WE
ALSO ECHOED THE COMMENTS- AIDED
BY LORI KAMMER EARLIER EARLIER A
PUBLIC COMMENT. SO AGAIN JUST
CALLING IN IN STRONG SUPPORT. OF
ITEMS H. FROM THE CHURCH THERE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WELL NOW GO TO
NUMBER SEVENTY EIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF THE
CATHOLIC GOVERNMENT AFFECT
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER HERE HE
WELCOMED THE INVESTMENT THE
NINETY THREE DIRECTLY TARGETING
TEENS RELATED TO IMMIGRANT
INCLUSION IN OUR STATE IN
PARTICULAR BACKING IN
INTEGRATING. OKAY ADDITION AND
BUILDING UP HE STAFF WITHIN GO
BID TO SUPPORT THINGS LIKE
AUTOMATION FIFTY FIRST STATE
LIKE CALIFORNIA HOME TO THE
LARGEST POPULATION OF IMMIGRANTS
WE HOPE TO SEE AN EXPANSION OF
THE STAFFING AND INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDED AT THE MOVE FORWARD. HILL
A FOCUS ON ENGLISH LANGUAGE
TRAINING LANGUAGE ACTIVE ABROAD
AND RESOURCES RELATED. TO
CITIZENSHIP. IN FINALLY GRAB
MONEY FOR LOW GUY. DECREE
FURTHER THE OWN IN INTO WORK
WITH A LOT AND- THE KEY COMPOUND
OF THE- THAT ARE BACK. TO SEE.
THE PROVINCIAL ENSURE ALL AREA
INCLUDING BORDER AND RURAL COULD
. THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA WILL
HAVE YUP. TO ENGAGE IN THE WORK
AT THE LEVEL THAT IT WAS A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
ENGAGING WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
LEGISLATURE IN THE COMPARTMENT
BATSMAN IN OUR STORAGE FEATURES
TO SUPPORT THE SEPARATE AS WELL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
ONE OH FIVE. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MATT BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS THEY JUST WANTED TO
SPEAK QUICKLY IN SUPPORT OF ITEM
TO YOU KNOWING THAT A ROBUST
RECOVERY IN THE HOSPITALITY AND
TOURISM INDUSTRY WILL
UNDOUBTEDLY BENEFIT OUR MEMBERS
AND RENTAL CARS AT CONVENTION
CENTERS AND- HOTELS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. NOW GO TO
LINE EIGHTY. CHECKERING ON
MEMBERS MARVIN BEEN AND ON
BEHALF OF INTERNATIONAL
LONGSHORE AND WAREHOUSE UNION
STILL COSTS THIRTEEN SIXTEEN
NINETY FOUR REPRESENTING TEN
THOUSAND WORKERS AT THE PUSH OF
OFFENDING THEM LONG BEACH BUT
HERE- TO SPEAK ON THE ISSUE
FIVE. ARE WE HAVE A STRONG OUR
CONCERNS REGARDING PUBLIC FUNDS
BEING USED. BY ANY ENTITY HAD
MENTIONED BY THE L. A. TO PROFIT
AT IN INTO MURATSUCHI OR
MICROMANAGE THE PRODUCTIVITY OF
OUR WORKFORCE BY MAKING SUCH AN
INVESTMENT RATED PRIVACY
CONCERNS OF WHAT THAT'S CORRECT
INFRINGING ON THE AISLE W'S
RIGHT TO COLLECTIVELY BARGAIN.
THIS IS THE NATURE OF THE DATA
HAPPENED. UP THE FEDERAL LEVEL
AND STRONGLY OPPOSE WITH OUR WE
ARE CURRENTLY AWARE LEAST THIRTY
SIX SOMETHING CAN TRACK. THERE
ARE DIFFERENT STAGES. OF
DEVELOPMENT. AT THE BUDGET
INCLUDES FOR PUBLIC FOR FROM
BEING USED TO OR DEVELOP A
SYSTEM. THAT WOULD HAVE TO PUT
OF COURSE. WORKFORCE MOST OF THE
CONTEST PROBLEM THE POOR. ARE
GENERATED AND WE WITHIN INCOME
BOTTOM YEARS. THEY HAVE THE
BENEFIT FROM HAVING CONTAINER
THAT AT THE- AND I'M MORE.
PUBLIC FUNDS SHOULD NOT BE-
CHEVY TRY FOR THE DATA SYSTEMS
TO WORK. IT WOULD. AT DIFFERENT
PACES AND THEY WILL NOT
COMMUNICATE WITH EACH. THAT
WOULD BE TO WEAPONIZE. AGAINST
WORKERS I THANK YOU FOR. BACKING
A CONCERNS. THANK YOU NEXT CALL
PLEASE. THE NEXT TO GO TO NUMBER
ONE TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. A
LINE TWENTY PLEASE MAKE SURE NOT
ON MUTE. WILL MOVE TO WIND OF
ONE THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON. HELLO YES BECAUSE YES
WE CAN OKAY THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS OF COURSE A
GOOD IN BETWEEN JAN I'M NOT
RESIDENTS OF MADERA COUNTY AND
I'M CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ITEM NUMBER. THREE IMMIGRATION
INTEGRATION AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME AND FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER. BUT A LINE ONE TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME I'M NOT A FAN OF. HI AM
CONTRACTS NOT CONFORMING- I AM
CALLING REGARDING TODAY ARE YOU
IN NUMBER THREE GRAYSON DELAY ON
ECONOMIC. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
COLOR. YEAH NOW WE DO HAVE
ANOTHER IN OUR QUEUE- WE'LL GO
TO LINE OF ONE THIRTY TWO. ONE
ONE THIRTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BUT WHY ONE THIRTY TWO EUROPEN.
OPEN AT SEVEN. AND THEN WE CAN
YOU. THE SEVEN THAT INVOLVED
YEAH LOW THEIR FRESNO CALIFORNIA
. HE DOWNLOADED BY THAT APPLE
YEAH. BUT APPLE YET IS THAT
THAT- YOU ECONOMIC CLOTHING
ATTENDING THE TO YOUNG. YES YES
. NEXT CALLER. AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO OTHERS IN QUEUE FOR
PUBLIC COMMENTS OKAY THANK YOU
MR OPERATOR APPRECIATE YOUR HELP
AND THANK YOU THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND OUR BUDGET STAFF
AS WELL THIS IS A HEARING IS
ADJOURNED.